there's no time o clock you guys out
there it's episode 187 yeah this one is
going to be I decided that I had to
because um over the past what comes is
laughing that's good yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's another missing persons one
yeah because uh over the past several
months probably even up to maybe a year
ago I've been getting recommendations
for missing persons cases to talk about
because I think we've done
- like compilation shows of missing
persons cases in the past so this would
be volume three of our creepy
disappearances I'm gonna talk about four
cases on here all of which were
requested by various people at various
times so I just thought I would kind of
put them all together people seem to
like these scary missing persons one
yeah as you can see we don't have a
studio ready we didn't get the chairs
yet yeah I mean but at least the
background looks a little bit better
than it's good I think it's good if I'm
gonna set it up so that's cool yeah I'm
trying to work the lights out yeah good
thing try to get better lighting
I'll look into upgrading this computer
so it can handle HD that - yeah I mean
ideally as well I would like to have the
studio like set up all the time yeah so
we didn't have to like keep moving just
turn it on and go yeah that would
because before I was like bringing in
chairs from the living room and all that
other kind of crap so yeah I ordered
some chairs as I said on the matinee
show on Sunday and they're supposed to
be here the day after this show I think
yeah we got a decent cameras just to the
computer can't really have a little
laptop we set it up several years old
and it's like yeah and way to put some
new cards in there I
we do yeah all right so just had a
couple of shout outs got a new patron
this week named Leander so hello and
welcome welcome to the show also one of
our patrons before who was already
giving quite a bit per month
their name is fade yeah they actually
increased significantly yeah yes very
large amount yeah he asked like Oh who's
your biggest what the biggest one person
was a subscriber you know I don't have
any answer to but anyway he said he
wanted to be number one we think it's a
guy writes a guy they think so all right
I would I would imagine so you know
that's that sounds like a guy thing it's
like I would so I think that's probably
the only shoutouts do we have any other
shout out so you want to give you want
to know like a coronavirus updater
talking about Corona Corona is just
tearing the place up we'll see we'll see
all right well the only thing I think
that's gonna affect is that and we've
kind of gone into this the last couple
weeks on theater it our matinee show is
that a lot of movies like a quiet place
to which we were gonna go see this week
and stuff like that have been like
pushed back until later in the year
because you know Mulan got pushed back
[ __ ] all pretty much everything got
pushed antlers got pushed back
everything got pushed back
so in our AMC Theaters I got an email
earlier today that said what they were
doing even though like no new movies are
starting they're like well what we're
gonna do is they're they're upping their
cleaning protocol you know in between
the movies and also they're only selling
like half the number of tickets that
they would normally sell like per
theater so people don't have to sit that
close together yeah which um I was like
well I don't see it being a problem like
filling theaters up if no new movies are
starting but they move James Bond back
double-oh-seven
they said it's for Corona and then it it
leaps that now they moved it back
because it sucked evidently like the
test the test audiences didn't like it I
don't know because like a look because
pretty much every other movie got
- like I said and I even had earlier
this week I checked to see in quiet
place - was supposed to start like this
upcoming Thursday night and when I
checked again all of the movies that
were supposed to start are gone they're
gonna [ __ ] James Bond up they're gonna
[ __ ] James Bond up just like they did
Star Wars just saying why why do you
have that attitude why do you have that
you don't know that that's why it is you
says some like Rando on YouTube like
said that's stupid crab [ __ ] it might
just be savory but like I said it might
just be because of the [ __ ]
coronavirus cuz everything else
literally every other movie got pushed
back as well like everything that was
supposed to start this week everything
that's supposed to start in April
everything got pushed back and I don't
even like know when they're gonna do it
like AMC announced that they were the
half you know only half ticket thing but
they're only selling like half the
number of tickets for each theater they
said they're gonna do that until April
30th and then they're gonna like
reassess it's not a bad feeling about it
didn't you were like all excited when I
saw the trailer he's like oh that looks
really good good I'm not talking about
them not talking about James Bond I'm
talking about the pandemic we're talking
about Corona when it started I had a bad
feeling about it and then that [ __ ] came
true because you know nostra [ __ ]
Thomas nostra Tom was like I said my
thing
tomorrow I think the problem is mostly
gonna be from people freaking out and
buying up I'm not freaking out I got
everything they don't yeah it's like I
got roof Koreans and everything I mean
you got what roof Koreans what the hell
are you talking about it's all in
Koreans you put up on a roof to keep
people out of the house you ever saw it
you didn't see that down the LA riots no
back back in the 90s now every Korea's
store had a bunch of Koreans on top of
it with shotguns wow they're [ __ ] that's
random their [ __ ] didn't get looted
dumped said I got my own roof Koreans I
mean that was a really random reference
like I don't know your track of [ __ ] man
I keep track of it you keep track of
[ __ ] from the 90s I keep track of the
price I don't even remember I like a lot
of codecs of the ages you know I mean
the Nexus of where everything [ __ ]
comes together I remember everything
yeah kind of like a gentle
and I can remember past lives everything
I just had a bad feeling about it you
know we did actually get a cat force we
did actually go to Captain D's and eat
lunch today though yeah posted it place
is empty all the people came in later
yeah but they weren't letting you
because before you could go to like the
little station and get your own
condiments and stuff they're not let you
do that anymore they have to
everything's like an individual package
why don't you then they have to like
stand back from a counter when you when
you order and then they were like well
cuz they got a work thing I was like you
know what I mean so they just kept like
they were like super like cleaning like
big time and then they had to bring you
like all of the condiments packets is
just us in like a table of three big old
black chicks over there eating all their
[ __ ] fish and we're like looking I'm
looking at the other one they're looking
at us like yeah and we're looking around
it's like dead in there a lot of people
in a lot of people in the drive-through
though yeah I did see a lot of people
drive there and when we were driving
around like it didn't really look like I
mean it looked pretty much like a
regular in that fish but had to get some
that seafood before the apocalypse man
yeah right sounded really good today
although I can't I mean when I eat lunch
there it's like I'm like well I can't
eat for two days now because I can
barely finish oh my have fun during the
apocalypse so what's Bretting
I went through Katrina already man this
is gonna be easy I'm like it's not kind
of like that's why it's kind of making
me mad that like all these people are
just like oh let's buy bottled water and
all this [ __ ] it's like it's not a
hurricane okay it's like you don't need
your taps still work yeah your toilet
still flushes yes you're fine I do not
foresee us losing power yeah it's like
that sucked way worse that's what made
Katrina so bad is because it was hot as
[ __ ] and it rained a lot for the first
few days and it was hot and it flooded
and it got into the fresh water so there
was no AC no power there was flooding
and there was no fresh water and the
people got trapped and there was no way
to get food to him and then there was no
way to get masses of people out of the
city
three days later man there's automatic
gunfire [ __ ] rapes and murders
the cops were stealing [ __ ] it got bad
there's a lot of stuff that got [ __ ]
erased from Katrina
there was videos used to be
on YouTube that were related to Katrina
that are now gone they don't want you
seeing that [ __ ] dead bodies laying on
the floor on the ground and stuff
Katrina was really bad it's not gonna be
that bad well that's what I'm saying
it's like even though I mean I live in
Florida and we've been through like some
hurricanes and I've been through like
some hurricanes that we're not really
bad but like you know the power would be
out for like more than a week and stuff
like that
so I'm just kind of like any this is
kind of like nothing as long as I still
have air conditioning and running water
I'm good yeah this day there's many
thousands of people still missing from
Katrina
I believe it a lot of them women
murdered and raped gone it was free yep
yes free we women were it doesn't cost
any money to kill people just gets no
great wall street
nope I think it was home invasions and
also stuff that happened inside of dam
buses and evacuation places you know the
man it just caught it a little bit here
and there it all kind of added up but
there are still thousands of people
missing yeah well like I said I believe
it if that was an apocalyptic disaster
so it's kind of like when when you see
stuff like that and like I said even
though I've never been through anything
as bad as Katrina I've been through like
some hurricanes where power was out
where my street was flooded where [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] we've even had like
[ __ ] brush fires that were worse than
that so it's I mean I'm just kind of
like y'all need to chill out I'm not
belittling anybody that's like in an
area where it's bad and if you want to
like wear masks and stuff that's on
that's you know do you do you but it's
like I'm just like don't worry I'll need
to chill out you need to chill out we
will not lose power I'm gonna talk you
all through this I got an email from my
sister earlier and they're actually
letting them work from home yeah
so she's in Georgia by the way yeah just
get some food man beans or rice well
according to a lot of people that are
that are out today everybody's buying
everything good buying everything here's
this deal here's our friend our friend
our friend Tom not not you but we have
another oh we got mini friends Tom's we
actually yeah I think it was big Tom
yeah
um because I was just like scrolling
through Facebook or Instagram or
whatever and he was in the Sam's and
Lake Mary that we go to yeah and he said
pretty much like all the meats gone like
all the [ __ ] like everybody that it
was packed and I mean it's always packed
on Saturday like we trying to never go
to Sam's on Saturday even when there's
not a pandemic because it's [ __ ] I
got more severe than in a man's ever
seen in one spot I got that flavored
spam smoked bacon flavored spam we have
I was posting that [ __ ] up sampling it
and I got jackasses on Tom Shean movies
talk about how bad [ __ ] spam is I'll
[ __ ] block your ass I just took the
comment away all right that [ __ ] keeps
up I will [ __ ] block you all right I
come from an army that was powered by
spam World War two was won on spam that
kept the American army in the Soviet
Army go it's not mystery meat its pork
shoulder pork shoulder and bacon
boneless cooked in the can [ __ ] good
it used to be a little too salty it's
not salty as it was yes well Pam's a lot
better I think because people had health
concerns about how much sodium was in
there I mean I think like stuff like
Campbell's soup and stuff like that I
think they toned down it's from the 20s
of this law yeah it's a preservative
yeah salt in it to preserve it but you
don't really need that you know you
don't need and like I said nobody wants
to [ __ ] and the flavor still wouldn't
cheat is shelf-stable forever you can
you can feed three people per can and a
meal out of that mix it with all kinds
of stuff and I like the bacon the smoked
and how opinio the flavored stuff's
pretty good I haven't tried the turkey
this podcast brought to you by Wright
this broadcast by spam may be the
sponsor of am the real cram if you've
ever played [ __ ] fall out for those
cram yeah there Tom it's spam but it's
like I know I love that they call cram
cram you slice it listen and fry it and
you can do it
it's like lunch me but better yeah I
still can't but yeah Tom rated needed no
yeah it's well the thing about it is
that even before I mean because we
always do like once a month we go to
Sam's and like just get [ __ ] on some
stuff so we just have some
[ __ ] food yeah I always get a
confession though man that's the
original and we've got like a year's
worth of house if we did like even
before you were before all that [ __ ] and
my friends in the [ __ ] guns and ammo
business man animal is just [ __ ]
selling out of the United States what
was that I don't know some fell over
ghost yeah go soon yeah yeah I don't
know what that was was what my knee
hittin underside of the desk I don't
know I don't think it was I thought it
was but yeah most [ __ ] selling out to
9-millimeter five five six [ __ ]
everybody's buying it up yep line it up
like I said everybody panicking about
stuff is gonna be way worse than know
what it is there's people come people
trying to get ready where there is no
shortage of food it's just that the
truck can't bring it fast enough yeah
you know it there will be food yeah
that's what I mean them nobody has to
really worry about there'll be food
just get some saved up a little bit I
think you know you can still find stuff
to eat yeah it's like it's there's still
stuff just not might not be the choice
stuff like and there's your stores
everywhere there's like some you know
it's like go to [ __ ] 7-eleven they
have like pea soup and Beefaroni and
[ __ ] like that if you really need that
people don't think to go there to buy
food so it's like it's you know yeah
Walmart and [ __ ] like that's gonna be
sold make a recommendation to everybody
listening there's a program on YouTube
called surviving Armageddon and it was
from it was a History Channel
documentary from prior like two thousand
five or six seven maybe no no is later
than that what's been 2010 it's for free
watch that it's about global pandemic
it's actually about a huge SARS outbreak
and the worst case scenario of what
might happen surviving the apocalypse on
YouTube go ahead and watch that it's
like a basic training video on how to
survive on apocalypse I recommend it to
anybody it's accurate a lot of it was
based upon what happened in Katrina yeah
alright so check it out alright so as I
said we're gonna be talking about four
different missing persons cases that
have been recommended to me
over the previous months and years that
I'm just now getting ready talking about
hold on one second what's that did I say
surviving the apocalypse that's not
what's called it was called after
Armageddon okay that's what it's called
it's on YouTube after Armageddon I think
I said surviving the apocalypse you did
yeah no I thought that's what it was
called but actually when I went back and
checked it it's called after Armageddon
on YouTube and it will come up there's
only one copy of it but good
I'm sure it's getting a lot of views it
actually I just checked it was only had
like a couple hundred thousand views but
sped up forever like eight nine years
yeah yeah so the first case I want to
talk about now this was technically a
missing-persons case for awhile but this
woman was found alive however the weird
thing is what happened in the interim
while she was gone you know I mean
that's what they're still investigating
so the most recent info I have on this
case is actually from Christmas Eve of
2019 so this is kind of where the
investigation is standing at this point
so this is the case of Cheri poppy knee
now when she was allegedly abducted it
was November 2nd 2016
now she was 34 years old at the time now
she was supposedly out jogging a mile
from her house which is in Redding
California now she went missing and then
three weeks later she was found a
hundred and fifty miles away like
wandering by the side of County Road 17
with like a chain like around her
midsection and around her wrists and
stuff like that now she said that she
was abducted by two Hispanic women yeah
I remember this who wore masks and had a
gun but she but during the whole three
weeks she was gone she never got a look
at their face she didn't know where they
took her and all this other so so yeah
and she had been branded to if I
remember correct yeah but the weird
thing about it is
yeah the weird thing about it is that
like a lot of info about how she was
found it's like it seems like the cops
and her husband are keeping [ __ ] on the
down-low and I'm not really sure why
that is might be part of the
investigation so yeah so there are some
people that I mean the cops are saying
we you know we don't have any reason to
like disbelieve that she was abducted um
but you know some other true crime
podcasts that I've seen about it saying
you know maybe that it was a hoax yeah
um so I don't really know where I stand
on that it's you know what I mean it
seems like a very strange thing to hoax
although weirder things from what I
remember you just getting up from what I
remember and haven't seen it looked at
the case recently you know I didn't know
you were gonna mention this one um the
police would not throw this case out
they thought it was credible she was
malnourished she was beaten she had been
branded with something yeah but they
wouldn't release they won't say like
what what had happened they believe and
on the back of that and it was two
Hispanic females but they ended up will
let her go for one for some reason or
another what I think happened was I
think some to Central or South American
girl price Central American girls that
had some connections with maybe
organized crime had some cockamamie kana
plan to abduct some girl and seller you
know they're mean yeah but maybe they
did this this was not a well thought out
type of thing and it turned out that
they weren't able to sell her so they
let her go that's what I think happened
yes it's possible you think you were
gonna try to sell it to like ms-13 or
Mexican mob or like sex trafficking so
sex trafficking sent her back down to
some central American company and put
her in a brothel but they probably just
did it kind of like on a whim not having
a buyer and not really having the means
they just thought maybe they could make
some money doing that that's what I
think or the buyer fell through
something like that yeah cuz it does
seem like a little bit yeah weird I
don't know it's just a really really
weird case so cuz they evidently did
they didn't really sexually assault her
they just stored her yeah and and beat
her and kind of mistreated her a little
bit
but then let her go yeah and the
difference evidently some kind of hoax
hoax re or in her past where they had
faked something years ago but it didn't
seem to be related to this so you know I
mean like some people say oh no they
faked a disappearance years ago but
evidently that was just kind of [ __ ]
that really didn't happen it wasn't I
don't believe it was a disappearance I
believe it was something more akin to
because I think and it you know please
forgive me if if I'm remembering this
wrong but I'm pretty sure that sherry
Pappy knee had had like some kind of
history of mental illness and she had
done some kind of thing with her family
where I don't I don't know she like
faked her own death or yeah there was
something like that like a long time ago
so she did kind of have a history which
is why like some people think that maybe
this was a hoax as well I don't think it
was um but you know what I mean it's
possible that I mean you know it would
be weird yeah that said that somebody
that had hoped something like that in
the past like had something like really
happened to them so I'm not gonna like
unless you know something else based on
what the police told the media well this
okay so this is basically what happened
and okay so it was November early
November 2016 she supposedly goes out
jogging like on this trail that's only
like a mile away from her house right so
her husband Keith comes home he worked
at Best Buy so he comes home in the
evening and his wife isn't home and
their kids aren't home now he says that
sherry always picked their kids up from
daycare and the fact that the kids were
not there and that he when he called the
daycare and the kids were still there
and said hey she never came and picked
them up so that immediately made him
very alarmed now they have his 911 call
where he's calling and reporting her
missing it's really weird because I you
know I don't like to judge because I
know some people you know when they're
calling to report stuff they sound like
super calm and everything that's what I
mean he but it was weird because he just
sounded very like casual well the weird
thing about it is that he's like okay so
he the kids aren't there he calls the
daycare they said yes she never showed
up Cheri never showed up and he
had an app on his field like Find My
iPhone so he did that to find her iPhone
and he found her phone like on the trail
where she had supposedly been running
and it was just like laying on the
ground and that with the earbuds kind of
like like someone had just like taking
the earbuds out of the pocket like laid
it on the ground and they were
apparently like strands of hair like
stuck on like somebody to kind of like
pulled the earbuds out of her ears so
and this was like a mile away from their
house so she's gone for like three weeks
and then like the day before
Thanksgiving a hundred and fifty miles
away somebody reports they see this
woman that's just like wandering kind of
they have like a little bit of video of
it but she's kind of like wandering up
and down like the side of the road and
she looks kind of skinny and beat-up and
she still has like restraints on so they
find her and she says that was two
Hispanic women in a dark-colored SUV she
didn't know if it was black or blue or
green or whatever she just said it was a
dark-colored SUV she said they either
always had masks on or kept a bag over
her head so she never really saw what
they looked like she said that one of
them was like kind of older and had like
straight dark hair like and kind of
thicker eyebrows whereas the other one
was a little bit younger and had thinner
eyebrows cause I guess when because I
have a picture of the UM you know like
the suspect sketches or whatever and it
looked like they didn't have full masks
on but it just had like that bandanas
they were like the bottom half of their
face you could still see like their eyes
and a little bit of their hair and stuff
so when Sheree is found she supposedly
weighs 87 pounds so they've starved her
somewhat her hair has all been cut off
not all of it but it's been you know cut
really short supposedly she had kind of
been beaten up her nose was broken and
she had a brand on her left shoulder
supposedly although police will not
reveal to the media what the brand is so
I don't know it was some kind of racial
slur I don't know if that's what it was
like that nothing I saw like the cops
just said that they weren't
what it was it's it's weird because I
you know I know this is like an ongoing
investigation and cops you know don't
usually like to comment too much the
media about an ongoing investigation
which lends credibility in my mind yeah
which maybe they do and they have they
but they have come forward and said
there's no reason to believe that that
she's making it up even though like I
said she did have kind of like a history
of that you know I remember at one point
one policeman asking a direct question
from somebody in the media and he was
like oh no I believe her that's that's
what yeah that's what he said yeah it's
so that means that there's you think
about it what's the motive yeah I mean
you have to break your own nose and
starve yourself for a long time yeah it
does seem away never fast he never
danced in on this well they did have a
GoFundMe Keith started a GoFundMe and I
believe they raised over $40,000 that's
pretty big that's a big [ __ ] way but
I don't think that's what the deal was
but yeah so I so I don't know that
doesn't necessarily mean anything
because a lot of people start good fund
means like especially when someone has
gone missing or they you know they want
to raise money for you know reward money
or things like that the police have
interrogation techniques they can get
down to the truth they can get down to
the bottom of it if this person that
hosts it I don't think they did yeah
yeah like I said it she passed their
test it seems like a crazy story but I
mean the cops do you seem to be taking
this fairly seriously um like I said
they they have come forward and said
that they do believe her that they're
investigating it although that they're
not like ruling anything out they did
say that also yeah they're just waiting
to see for more information yeah but
they have they have actually had they've
released like 20 search warrants and
they've gone through like bank records
cell phone records you know social media
profiles of various people and things
like that but they are not saying like
who the search warrants were against or
anything like that they have given Keith
the husband they gave him a polygraph
which he passed although he said
although investigators have said that
they're not ruling out that he had
something
to do with it uh what does that mean
well that's what I mean they said we're
just keeping all possibilities open
although they did note that he did have
a polygraph test having something can do
it it can be interpreted to mean meaning
yeah now they did say they they did say
that they thought that maybe Keith had
been just from the things that he said
to the media might have been
compromising their investigation a
little bit so I'm not entirely sure what
that means
um so the strange thing though is that
even though sherry was gone for 22 days
and was apparently in the custody of
these people or more people than the
ones that took her she doesn't have a
real or at least as far as anyone knows
she doesn't have any idea of like where
she was being kept or how many people
there were or she's not she doesn't seem
like she's been real forthcoming about
what happened all that time or where she
was or why they let her go
or anything like that at least not that
they're releasing to the public you know
what I'm saying they're probably keeping
that under wraps I would think yeah it
may be so it's like I'm not really sure
this is as I said still an active
investigation
all this information that I was this
actually came out in People magazine on
Christmas Eve of 2019 so that's the let
that's the most recent thing about it
and I imagine that they're still
investigating this and there's still a
$10,000 reward for information so if
anybody has any information on this
woman's case about who took her or you
know and anything else about her she had
a lot more details about what where they
took her but they're not releasing that
to the public that's kind of what I'm
thinking it's like maybe they're just
trying to maybe they kind of have
suspicions and now apps aren't gonna
[ __ ] give up and you know they're not
I mean it yeah it's not something that's
you know happened such a long time ago
or they're trying to like jog people's
memories I mean you know this only
happened like a few years ago I'm gonna
say it was something hokey and
amateurish that's what it was yeah you
know like when they took Elizabeth Smart
yes some dude he was gonna have a whole
haribol wives so you just kind of kept
her in a trash pile for a little while
but you got out yeah you know I mean
well they didn't know when they didn't
know where she was you can dream up any
old scenario to scare the [ __ ] out of
yourselves really what it was just some
hokey [ __ ] took her yeah you
know it's gonna be something kind of
like that some hokey ass chicks decided
to take another woman and try to sell
her but they didn't have the means to do
so it was something like that yeah maybe
they just kind of like thought of it
which sounds like a weird thing to do
but you know I thought thinking let's go
catch a white girl and sell her
yeah but then they didn't know who to
sell her to yeah I didn't get for a baby
but they didn't really they think they
thought that that would be easier than
it what we had I mean they thought that
would be easier to do in reality than it
really is yeah because you know they
probably don't know anybody Mexican mob
would be like women who touching that
you might be FBI ya know something like
that you have to have contacts right or
me it was just to do that kind of [ __ ]
maybe it was something kind of culty I
don't know that's a possibility also
hope I have you out of that cults do
weird [ __ ] yeah
and maybe it was kind of like them
trying to a cult of two crazy [ __ ]
trying to get a third one and make her
like a recruit in some weird way but
they haven't let haven't given us that
information yet yeah maybe something
like that yeah that's possible so they
were trying to do it do it
remember all like Patty Hearst they're
trying to do like a Patty Hearst thing
yeah we're they're journaling brain
washer and convert her into one of their
eyes might be something like that but
the cops haven't given us the
information yeah might've been something
like that the only thing um that came
out later on was that they did actually
find DNA of two people they found male
DNA on the clothing that she was found
wearing which I don't believe belonged
to her so they found male DNA there and
they also found a female DNA like on her
body when they examined her like at the
hospital now both of these DNA profiles
have been uploaded to the CODIS database
however
they do not match any previous DNA that
is on file so that's kind of going
nowhere now the only other Avenue that I
know of that they were exploring is that
sherry Pappy nee apparently had a male
friend they're not really saying whether
this was like a romantic relationship or
anything like that this guy lived in
Michigan and they found like a bunch of
texts and phone calls between the two of
them going back like several years so
you know they're keeping that
possibility open also that maybe she
faked it like to go live with this guy
or to go run off with this other dude
and then like she got cold feet and
decided not to or something like that
she's a star herself yeah they're
leaving that open as a possibility but
as I said they're you know they're like
the you know the relationship that she
had with this guy they're not making it
clear whether it was just like an old
friend that she had who happened to be a
guy because they actually apparently had
known each other for several years or
whether there was a romantic
relationship going on such that she
would have like you know wanted to take
off and like leave her husband over it
and couldn't just do you know about it
the normal channel thinks the whole
thing and then cook this story up there
might be a possibility but don't have to
break your own nose and cut your own
that's what I mean that's the only thing
that's the only thing I mean because
I've been watching like a couple
different like true true crime podcasts
where they were talking about this and
it does seem like a lot of them kind of
are leaning toward her like faking it
just because it sounds like a
far-fetched kind of thing to happen yeah
but a lot of the [ __ ] we've covered on
this [ __ ] program but are very
far-fetched but it was true yeah and and
I mean I would be more you know yes they
raised more than $40,000 on GoFundMe and
no one really knows what they did with
that money um you know even though I
assumed that they started raising it
like for reward money like for
information when she was still missing
so no one really knows where that went
now some people were like oh maybe she
did it for attention but the thing about
it is that she's not really I mean she's
kind of gone into hiding like since this
case has been she hasn't come out and
given interviews or anything like that
like every now and then her husband
come out and like say some [ __ ] but it's
like it's not like they're trying to
like hog the spotlight or like get all
yeah you know what I mean anything like
that so yes she did have like a history
of mental illness yes she did have a
thing where she you try to fake her own
death or you know tried to make her
family think she had committed suicide
or something like that like several
years in the past so some people have
been speculating that maybe she had
mental issues and concocted this whole
thing but like you said that's kind of
breaking your own nose yeah well if
you're crazy though maybe you might do
that I don't know and then you go live
out in the woods and then put on some
hobo clothes and come back 22 days later
but you got to have some crazy has to be
strong in you to do something to that
extent
and most crazy people are [ __ ] flimsy
they won't you know I mean they won't go
through it you know I mean that's pretty
profound crazy - yeah you gotta have it
yeah you gotta be dedicated to the crazy
and most crazy people are wishy-washy
they'll do it for six seven eight hours
and think oh I'm done and then they go
back home yeah yeah I'm done with this
stunt yeah I think she got abducted or
yeah or she faked it she got abducted
which that's not an answer much it I
mean it could be either thing cuz then
you had to brand yourself and that's
what I mean that's the only thing that
kind of bit it would be different if she
because some you know some other true
crime podcast porn it's like oh it seems
interesting that she came back like
right before like the day before
Thanksgiving like she didn't want to
like leave her family cuz she had kids
and [ __ ] yeah so it's like she don't
want to leave her kids behind like on
Thanksgiving and she changed her mind
about maybe she was running off with a
dude or something like that
but the fact that she supposedly had a
brand that her nose was supposedly broke
in that she had supposedly lost I don't
know how much she weighed before but she
apparently weighed 87 pounds when she
got back um so she I mean she looked
like a very small woman so I you know I
and it's three weeks so how much weight
can you lose in three weeks if you're
not eating much quite a bit well that's
true because we watched what's that
[ __ ] naked and afraid yeah I can they
always tell you like how much and I
think they do that for three weeks don't
they it's 21 days right so yeah yeah and
some of them leaves like yes I'm
like 14 pounds 22 the dudes always lose
more which pisses me off so much it's
like the same event like the the dude
and the woman are eating the same amount
of food and like the dudes like it he
lost 30 pounds I'm like you [ __ ] and
then the woman lost like eight pounds we
age in dog years every time I see that
it always amazed me go makes me so angry
I think she I think I think she was
abducted yeah like I said if she if she
came back like after less than 22 days
and she wasn't like all beat up and
stuff yeah and then I would maybe be
more likely to believe that she faked
the whole thing but I don't know you'd
have to be really she was really
committed to she was gonna fake it she's
gonna be gone for a couple days yeah
that's it she would get a tray that
she's fooling around with some dude she
get the dick and then she'd get she get
sick of it she get addicted as you get
sick of the dick [ __ ] she cook and go
back home and tell this big old [ __ ]
story but there's nothing really back it
up yeah nose is broke and she's got
[ __ ] she's skinny as [ __ ] she's
branded she's her original clothes are
gone she sacrificed her own man I think
some he abducted her men but like you
said it seemed like they didn't really
like think they know they went with it
was some kind of hook he [ __ ]
cockamamie [ __ ] planned these people
[ __ ] cooked up yeah think of the
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] we've talked about on
this second program for the past couple
years imagine if somebody like Edmund
Kemper got ahold of your ass but you got
away yeah yeah I mean and then you told
the e or just what's the craziest
[ __ ] we've talked about Jesus
Christ
imagine the [ __ ] that they would do yeah
and then you go back and tell the
authorities and they're like dude that
was collecting dead [ __ ]
yeah what was his name Ed Gein no no no
the other one the one the one that made
the doll and oh yeah oh that necrophile
I guess a man using the tube for a [ __ ]
I hate to be dirty about it but come on
you guys are regular listeners you know
who I am
we're all adults here already halfway to
that drink I guess it just saying
there's some crazy [ __ ] that people do
that if you were just some random person
and you got a and you got mixed up with
this guy and then you went told the cops
they would probably wouldn't believe you
yeah at first if you didn't have any if
you did know that because that's a crazy
story
yeah but it happens right I mean crazy
stuff it's not that common so you can
see why cops would be like nah you were
exactly but like the dude does happen
every now and then like the dude with
the boy board yeah what was his name
Munna Dean Corll right Dean Corll what
happens at Candyman what happens if that
if Dean Corll got hold of your ass and
you're your teenage dude who's got who's
running you know you've had trouble with
the law [ __ ] smoke a dumb stealin [ __ ]
and then you run to the cops and you say
yes guy tied me to a board had my
brother on the other side of the board
made me beat my own brother to death was
sticking glass rods and sticking glass
rods up it might and my dick and
crushing them the cops [ __ ] wouldn't
believe you they probably wouldn't
they're good you're full of [ __ ] yeah
and then they would go pull it out yeah
and then you pull it out and you show
them all that [ __ ] glass damage and
they might go you're bullshitting you're
making it up you did that to yourself
you're in to imagine that yeah that's
some kind of kinky gay [ __ ] you come up
with that's how the cops would come at
you well yeah that didn't happen you can
see why some [ __ ] doesn't get reported
yeah yeah and they tracked down Dean
Corll he talks his way out of it yeah
well he's got all his dead boys up in
the damn storage unit buried underneath
the ground you know he's a proud
military man he would never do that
that's what they always ya can tell a
lot of [ __ ] they said that about John
Wayne JCM such a nice man a lot of [ __ ]
depends upon belief yeah even Bela
Lugosi we was playing Dracula Dracula
says my biggest power is that you don't
believe it remember what about in the
Bible about the dead
I don't know that that was don't worry
god that was like the devil I don't
remember Bauer's that people don't
believe in a mercy yeah yeah I don't
remember the exact line but I don't
either
Bella [ __ ] says that [ __ ] just slick
his [ __ ] you don't a man like that's
cool as he was you know it amazes you
know what I'm one of the biggest powers
is that mankind does not believe yeah
that this is possible you know so I
would say that I would say that there's
a good chance yes some have this woman I
think so I'd give her an 80% I kind of
would - it's like you know I don't I
don't like to like stigmatize people
that have mental issues and maybe you
know because bad [ __ ] can happen to
those people too so I mean it as far out
there I think I think maybe something
happened to her and the fact that she
had like strangers DNA on her then they
still don't know who the [ __ ] DNA that
is or if they do know they're not
telling anybody but you know I think
there's an 80% chance that she's telling
the truth I think she does too and that
and I think there's about and also an
80% chance that the cops have not told
us to everything that they know well
they're clearly not because and like I
said you can't blame them because it's
an ongoing investigation and they don't
want like you know the story that we're
telling here is just a based upon what
the police have decided to tell us
there's gotta be more to this story we
don't know yeah and I'm sure that she
has been interviewed at length I'm sure
her husband has been interviewed at
length and I'm sure that they that both
of them have told the cop stuff that the
cops are not releasing right the cops
needs to miss information - yes they as
well well because that's how you um you
know you sift through like people that
cuz there's all kind of people that will
report so you people that'll like
confess to crimes that did that they
didn't do it yes you people as the
listeners the story we just tap we just
told you guys is the story that the
police put out yeah may be false yes
some of that [ __ ] might not be true yes
like I said that's they don't do it to
be me and they just do it they do it as
part of the investment as part of the
investigation yeah because like I said
that's the only way they can get through
good because their people will come in
like confess to [ __ ] right um that they
didn't do look at [ __ ] Henry Lee
Lucas for Christ's sake yeah they'll put
out false [ __ ] and if you come in
you could fall [ __ ] that's kind of true
but not really yeah and then people come
for sit I did that and then they'll and
then they said well really what happened
they tell the same [ __ ] story that
the police put out the police no that
was good nope
cuz that's a fake story you go home go
and take your meds right yeah so like I
said that's pretty much all they know
and that and that was the most recent
like I said the most recent news story
about it that I could find is from
Christmas Eve of 2019 and that was in
People magazine so I would assume that
that is the most the most recent
information that they have so the next
one I want to talk about it and somebody
recommended this and actually I'm kind
of upset that I hadn't heard that much
about this one cuz this happened right
here in Orlando Florida where we are
right now this is the disappearance of
Jennifer Cassie now this woman has not
been found she disappeared in 2006 early
2006 and they still have no idea where
she is
good no it really doesn't um and yeah
this is really creepy so yeah what ended
up happening I think she was originally
from Tampa because she graduated from
high school over there and then she went
to UCF University of Central Florida and
graduated in 2003 she had a degree in
finance so in 2006 when she disappeared
she was working as a finance manager at
Central Florida investments time
timeshare company and that's in Ocoee
which is a suburb of Orlando I actually
used to work in a print shop over an
Ocoee so I know exactly where that is
now shortly before her disappearance she
had bought a condominium in a new
building near the mall at millennia we
know that where that is what they're
doing that okay
the neighborhood around where the Mahlum
malt Maleny is is is kind of a high
crime area but they're trying to like
gentrify it so they built the mall at
millennia which is like a really really
nice mall and then they started building
like all these really nice like condos
and apartment complexes and stuff like
that around it because they're trying to
essentially like push out like all the
old neighborhoods that are kind of like
high-crime yeah they're not making any
money yeah
happens a lot so the building that she
lived in like that she bought a condo
and it was like brand-new
and I think either she was the only one
in the building or there was only like
one other tenant so far this is like a
brand-new building and I believe it was
in within walking distance of mall at
millennia so now the weekend before she
went missing she had actually been on a
vacation with her boyfriend Rob Allen
now Rob Allen is they were in a like a
long-distance relationship he actually
lives in Fort Lauderdale which if you're
not from Florida is about three or four
hours from here
so they just kind of like you know they
tried to see each other every weekend
they would drive back and forth and like
you know do FaceTime or whatever but
they have been to st. Croix in the
Virgin Islands like the weekend before
she went missing
now they came back on the Sunday night
and she stayed at his house in Fort
Lauderdale and then drove back to
Orlando and like went to work that day
like at six of which I don't know how
she wasn't [ __ ] tired but okay
because that's a long drive if you
didn't know so she's your official ei4
yeah well actually that congestion from
the old life well it would most it would
be 95 am i thinking like 95 over to I
for I guess it would be because Fort
Lauderdale you'd have to take 95 upset
cuz I for only goes east west I'm there
might be no better than me sure she grew
up here yeah yeah I'm from here okay I
mean I don't know all the roads and
stuff cuz I've only been to Fort
Lauderdale once or twice in my whole
life
cuz that's way too far it's way too [ __ ]
down there interviews at like Florida
it's long that's near the Scientology
base in it no no it isn't okay
Clearwater that's a where on the west
coast
that's my Tampa all right right right
right like if there's a bender
Clearwater yeah Tampa Clearwater in
Saint Pete or like three massive cities
and they're all just it's one big like
mega city it really I never been in a
Fort Lauderdale I've been there um two
times I think I went to some fetish
parties down there yes I'm [ __ ] like
there's a fetish parties well I used to
back in the old days well like no I did
you had this yeah I did it's just after
I lost a bunch of weight and they come
so yeah so she drives from Fort
Lauderdale back to back to Orlando and
goes straight to work now
while they'd been on vacation I think
they were um they were in st. Croix for
like a week while they had been on
vacation her 21 year old brother Logan
had been staying at her condo like with
her permission I guess he had had some
friends there they'd have a party your
son only been in trash it or anything
like that apparently but um but they had
been staying there
now either Logan or one of his friends
had left his cellphone at the condo like
when they left so one of the phone calls
that they had between her and Logan like
before she disappeared was was her
saying yeah I found this cell phone like
I'll mail it to you or you can come pick
it up or whatever so the last time that
Jennifer Casey was seen she was leaving
work at 6:00 p.m. on January 23rd 2006
now according to everyone that knew her
her boyfriend her parents everything
like that she was very very very safety
conscious and had probably become more
so since moving into this particular
condo because she said that you know the
the area around there the the condo
where the condo is is nice but it's like
you know the the area is surrounding
that is kind of like a high crime area
also there was so much like construction
and some of the other condos were still
under construction or being renovated or
whatever so there was like a lot of
workers like just wandering around the
property and she said that a lot of them
had like you know cat called her and
like sexually harassed her and stuff
like they would always like yell at her
when she was like going out shoo and it
made her uncomfortable so she had like a
rape whistle she had like the whole [ __ ]
and she's like any time she was walking
to and from her car like you know at the
thing she would always have somebody on
the phone you know so she would always
call like all the time either her
brother or her parents or her boyfriend
or something to note to let them know
where she was so she's talking to her
dad on the phone about 6:15 p.m. and
that's when she was driving home from
work she called her boyfriend Rob at
about 10:00 p.m. like I said he was in
Fort Lauderdale
now the next morning what she would
normally do is she would usually call
her boyfriend or text him
for she left for work she did every day
and they said she's very very like
habitual in that way as she was always
very careful about letting everybody
know where she was because she lived
alone so um so he thought it was very
weird that on that morning he didn't get
a phone call or a text from her before
before he she went to work so he called
and the her phone went right to
voicemail now he was concerned but he's
like well maybe she's just really busy
or whatever and he had a meeting that
morning at work so he didn't he was
worried but he wasn't like panicking or
anything like that now the next thing
that happened is that Jennifer Cassie
did not turn up at work and this was
also very unusual because she was very
conscientious and immediately her
manager and all her co-workers became
very alarmed because she had not called
in or anything like that so the manager
at the place where she worked
called her parents now her parents live
two hours away I assume in Tampa because
that's where she went to high school so
he so he calls the parents and they
start driving to Orlando so they can all
kind of get together and figure out
where she went
now when the parents get to her condo
I guess they apparently did a spare key
or they knew where she kept a spare key
or whatever so they saw that her car was
gone
she had a black Chevy Malibu I believe
it was a 2004 they saw that her car was
gone but they were like okay well that's
not that unusual so they went into her
condo and nothing seemed amiss they said
it looked like there was like a damp
towel on the bed the shower was still
wet from inside her bed wasn't made like
there were some clothes laid out her
makeup was kind of like out and like she
had gotten up taking a shower gotten
ready for work like she normally would
there was no sign of a struggle there
was no sign of forced entry like the
condo was locked and everything like
that so you know that's a little strange
so but the car was gone the car was gone
but they found it later I'll tell you
okay so they thought they're like okay
so what must have happened is that she
got up got ready for work left her condo
like she usually did on her way to work
and
must have been abducted at some point
while she was walking toward her car
like in the morning yeah now January
26th which was a couple days later they
found her 2004 Chevy Malibu parked at
another apartment complex about a mile
away now initially investigators were
excited about this because they found
out that this particular apartment
complex had hidden cameras and that the
cameras were pointed basically right
toward where her car was parked so they
were like woohoo we'll we'll see who put
it there so they watched the tape
unfortunately you can see a person
getting out like parking the car getting
out of the car and walking past the
fence and everything like that but
because the fence is like so it's this
kind of like elaborate black like
wrought iron fence or whatever you can
see the person but you can't tell if
it's a man or a woman and you can't tell
what their face looks like they're like
it looks like a white person could be a
Hispanic person could be a man could be
a woman they're really not entirely sure
because the camera only took an image
like every few seconds and they said
this person was walking and every time
the camera took a picture their face was
like behind a thing of the fence so they
couldn't see what the person looked like
they said all they know is that and
they've like sent the tape to like
[ __ ] NASA and the FBI and everything
like that like for enhancement they said
all they can tell is that the person is
about five foot four or five foot five
it's a shortcut that's or or it could be
a woman but they don't really know they
said the interesting thing is that so
they said they found the car the car
appeared to have been wiped down that
all they found was like a single latent
print and like a little bit of DNA fiber
but it didn't like lead to anything so
the weird thing though is that this
person because I've kind of watched the
little surveillance video it doesn't
look like the person was like in a rush
or anything like that they were I mean
they even like parked in the spot and
then like they kind of were crooked so
they kind of backed up and did it again
and they were just like walking
like normal this confident he got away
with this was about noon that he parked
the part of the southern apartment no it
was a couple of days later you see he
kept a car for a couple days yeah weird
I mean or it might have been the same
day because I think they didn't they
didn't find the car until a couple of
days later so I think the video so yeah
I think it was actually noon if she had
vanished at some time like around 7 or 8
on the morning I don't think anything is
a coincidence he knew she was there he
has seen her that's what I think yeah I
think he knew what time she went to work
it might have been somebody that was
watching her but yeah and he was like I
won't get her I'm gonna get her next
time yeah and then he walks up arm pulls
it points a gun at her toes they get in
the car yeah because she she must have
come out of her apartment or her condo
yeah because it was locked and he told
her some kind of story and got her to
drive him somewhere that he knew about
where it was more deserted yeah raped
and killed her
that's probably I'm kind of in the car
yeah so they said they went through the
whole car and it looked like it had been
wiped down
they also found like they they were like
clearly robbery was not the motive
because like nothing was nothing of
value was like taken from the car
however some of her things are missing
all of her clothes and her new shoes
that she had been wearing that day which
they knew because she had just bought
them and told people about it and they
didn't find them in her apartment her
cellphone is missing her iPod is missing
her keys her Basheer's learn them though
and her briefcase yes so those are all
things that are missing the cell phone
they have tried to ping it but it's
apparently off so they haven't found it
her bank account key card or her ATM
card has not been used since she
disappeared so he knew about all that
yeah so maybe so or he just wasn't
interested in that so he just left it
with the body yeah so um as they would
normally do the first thing they do is
start with you know family members or
you know boyfriends ex-boyfriends things
of that nature which they usually do now
her boyfriend was one of the first
people that they interviewed but he had
it
alibi he was four hours away in Fort
Lauderdale he'd been at work you know
and they could prove that she did have
an ex-boyfriend who had been very upset
about their breakup and had been
according to several other friends had
been trying to get back together with
her so they did interview him
extensively and later ruled him out
although you know like I said everybody
had said they were trying to get back
together I think he was random yeah what
so here's what the thing was that like I
said she had been complaining and she
had complained to her family about this
that because she was either the only
tenant in this building or there was
like maybe only one other tenant because
it wasn't finished yet they were still
like working on the other condos so all
of so there was workers running around
all the time you know what I mean like
working on this stuff and building stuff
and she said that a lot of them would
ahead like harassed her and stuff now a
lot of them were like speaking Spanish
but she spoke Spanish too so she knew
what they were saying so a lot of those
people were interviewed but they didn't
really seem to know anything
I just can't Collin yeah there yeah they
were not calling her but she said it
happened so much that it was like
starting to bother her um you know which
is why she kind of like complain about
it now so this so they are not sure if
something you know went there like some
guy had that worked there like SAR and
decided he was gonna like kidnap her a
raper another thing that they went then
they went started interviewing her
co-workers now apparently they took like
a bunch of computers like they took her
computer and some other computers from
the workplace and one of the managers at
her workplace had been trying to ask her
out like repeatedly and she had turned
him down because she said you know look
I have a boyfriend I don't date
co-workers or whatever now apparently
I'm not really sure because like the
Wikipedia page doesn't go into this but
I was watching like another true crime
podcast about this and it was another
guy that was from Orlando and he kind of
knew a lot about the case and he said
that this co-worker
that was into her was had like some kind
of sketchy friends and like some kind of
sketchy but I don't know if it was like
drug dealing or it was something like
that like so he had some kind of like
sketchy like criminal kind of [ __ ] going
on so sound right to me
so yes but that's another possibility
that they've been exploring they he was
interviewed like a whole bunch of times
the cops have supposedly ruled him out
you know even though like I said he had
like been trying to ask her out like a
bunch of times I mean that does happen
so it sounds like normal life [ __ ] to me
I think the cops are maybe much into
maybe if you ask me that sounds like
something where you have a guy who's
kind of an unemployed type dude maybe in
between jobs kind of lower income he's
young and he just walks around a lot you
know maybe he's going to that mall he
said there was a mall near that yeah
money and he sees I've been there he
sees her and remembers her yeah he's got
kind of a boring life he decides he's
gonna abduct her and rape and kill her
and he's kind of easy [ __ ] back yeah you
know I mean and then he pulls that off
yeah I mean it's possible that it could
just be a random person or or yeah or
somebody that worked at the building
like briefly or somebody that was in the
building for some other reason like I
see her right and decided they were just
gonna abduct her one day you know what I
mean so somebody that had like motive
and a time to do it yeah a lot of
working guys yeah it's a [ __ ] it's hard
to say that because then you got dudes
like beat yeah I was gonna say he had a
job and a whole family BTK is way back
there on the show yeah girl x-factor
yeah well you know factor X Factor he's
trying to make X Factor's 2 factor of
sex you know sex butt-head [ __ ]
trying he's he's such a dork man he's
such a dork but yeah so even though like
this now this just [ __ ] I like I
don't know if because it does really
seem like
the cops have kind of like not really
been because I feel like they told the
friends and family this is what I heard
but that they told the friends and
family that they'd been working on the
[ __ ] but then when the friend when the
family like hired a private investigator
the investigator was like yeah they
haven't been doing jack [ __ ] no he's
like yeah so they don't know anything so
this is what happened like back in 2006
and they still don't really know
anything now the manager where she
worked or the CEO or whatever he
actually offered a $1,000,000 reward
with the stipulation that she be found
alive but no one ever claimed it so
she's still like the FBI got involved in
the case everything like this now what
ended up happening was that the the
Cassie family hired a private
investigator now the private
investigator they came up they came up
with something that either the cops
didn't I don't know how they could have
missed this or they didn't follow up on
it sufficiently but apparently even back
in 2006 when she disappeared a witness
said that they had seen a guy dumping a
rolled-up carpet into Fisher Lake which
is about 30 miles from where she
disappeared and it looked like it had
something in it so he did like report
that so the family followed up on that
they got some they got people to like
search the [ __ ] lake
they got cadaver dogs out there and now
the cadaver dogs did seem interested
that there was something in there but
apparently they dragged the lake and
they haven't found a body however at
this stage in the last update that I saw
in this particular case was from March 6
2020 so at this point the family is
trying to like either raise the funds or
get permission or something like that to
drag the lake again because they think
that that might be where her body is
and because another thing too is that
significantly like I said this person
said that they saw somebody dumping a
rolled-up carpet into this lake the
condo across the hall from her condo had
a piece of carpet missing and no one was
living in it it was being renovated or
it was just so he's still under
construction
yes so it looked like some carpet was
missing from there so somebody's
thinking that they put her in the carpet
and dumped her he went out of his way
usually yeah opportunity just kind of
just jump them they just dump them on
side of Rossi but that's what makes me
think that it was maybe somebody that
knew her or somebody that I mean it
could have been the co-worker it could
have been the ex-boyfriend I mean trying
to hide yes baby was rolled out yes
they've been ruled out but that doesn't
mean that they didn't do it I just it
just seems like well if you were gonna
like he's trying to hide the body
because there is a link between it
that's what I'm saying if it was just
some Rando likes like a guy that worked
in the building or something cuz she
said she was worried about them
catcalling yeah they don't worry
they wouldn't I mean normally you would
think if they were just gonna rape and
kill her they would just like leave her
somewhere like in the building cuz it's
mostly empty like why would they go to
the trouble to drive thirty- was correct
and that's what he saw why would they
drive 30 miles with her body rolled up
in a carpet yeah yeah if you didn't have
any like relations yet there's no
connection they usually just let them
they would just let yeah because they're
like wolves they don't know that person
so it's like it's harder to let letting
letting the person be found there's no
skin off their nose because there's no
connection yeah I mean if they took care
to like keep their DNA off right and
there's no you know that they wouldn't
have any reason even if they didn't do
that they wouldn't really have any
reason and you know unless they have
like a prior conviction where their DNA
had been taken then they wouldn't really
have that much because they would never
be brought in as a suspect
it's a weird missing person case but you
know there's a lot of missing a lot of
the cases we've already talked about
that were solved later we're missing
person cases from a long time ago this
guy may have killed others this month
this might be a serial killer although
like I said the fact that probably is
the fact that if they do end up finding
her body and Lake Fisher and it was like
wrapped in that carpet and stuff like
that I'm I think that suggests that it
was somebody that knew her maybe maybe
not somebody that was close maybe not
like the ex-boyfriend or anything like
that but maybe it was somebody that I
mean obviously it was somebody that knew
where she lived and [ __ ] like that they
didn't break into her house she left the
condo and locked the door and it was
like morning time it wasn't like night
or any
nowadays they usually find out yeah
actually usually the usually they
eventually find the body
usually they eventually find the killer
it might take a decade but it's not like
it was back a long time ago where you
can make a person disappear then you
know I mean and it just kind of well I
don't know maybe it is still kind of
like that it's you know I guess it
depends and Emily because we don't
really know the true numbers yeah and to
be honest I think a lot of it depends to
on you know how how much the family
pushes to find to find the person and
like you know how much they harass the
police about investigating it and stuff
like that I mean in this case her
parents have hired private investigators
and they're just constantly bugging the
police about like [ __ ] doing [ __ ]
about it sometimes what happens is that
they find a body yeah but then that body
isn't identified as that person that's
missing so for all we know they have the
body they may have found the body in
another state yeah that's possible a lot
of its missing yeah I mean so she's not
identified they just you know that
happens a lot to you I write about like
a lot of cases like that in my book and
that's like that happens it's like
depressingly off yeah if you go to like
the [ __ ] site where they have like
all the unidentified bodies that they
found on bodies horrifying yeah it's
horrifying how many there are
well they have no idea who these people
are because like you said if they were
say they were a runaway or say they were
kidnapped and taken across state lines
like back in the 70s or something like
that and if they were taken all the way
across the country and murdered and just
left in a ditch someplace it's like no
one would ever wouldn't make that
connection right as to like who's that
you know if they [ __ ] vanished from
Michigan and now it's now they're in
[ __ ] you know South Carolina it's
like no one's gonna hook that [ __ ] up
the person's families are old and dead
yeah looking for them there was never
really any dental records done just it
just makes me really sad like every time
that I because I go to that's you know I
go to that site a lot because you know I
write about a lot of those cases but it
just makes me sad how supportive how
many there are
yeah this is a big [ __ ] country and
it's like you know find bodies and they
don't know who that is
yeah and sometimes they never know yeah
it's like it always kind of makes me
happy but at least they
identify somebody because they do I mean
they do keep working on them it's like
obviously they don't have the manpower
to have some people working on these
cases full-time IRA but I remember back
in like in the 80s on unsolved mysteries
they found a damn body I think was
somewhere out in New Mexico or something
found this dead body mummified inside a
little trunk or up up in a wall lock or
something like that or you know I mean
like a wall yeah Locker and it was just
some long-haired girl with little
moccasins on and they don't didn't know
who that was just moccasin was a little
bead some a little bit like you'd have
yeah these little beads long black hair
and a little moccasins
yeah they don't know who that was that
might be there was a case like that I
can't remember um yeah I thought that
might be a different one but I think
that one of those women I think that had
moccasins on I think that she had she
was identified but I don't know if
that's the same one or not because like
I said there's they showed there's so
many and I remember seeing a pitcher her
mummified face yeah and then they tried
to do a drawing to kind of read Greek
history yeah what she looked like and
this is back in the 80s you know all
that did he did he did it from unsolved
mysteries man I gotta love that show I
do too but uh yeah and they were like
who is this woman you know I mean and
last I had heard they still hadn't
identified who that was yeah maybe they
have I should look that up you it was
Arizona I think mass heart you know it's
a long time yeah Mexico Arizona it was
in it like I said there's so many and
it's like and it happens all the time
like I said it's usually women they
usually stay for out of like women get
found out in a trunk are teenagers I
think they found her in a trunk and some
kind of an abandoned building and she'd
been dead for [ __ ] when they found
her she was dead six seven years yeah
tried out like a mummy in there yeah
they didn't know who was scared that
must have been around 87 I think when
that program is six when that came out
weird but yeah so um yeah so like I said
the FBI and everybody like that has got
involved in this Jennifer Cassie case
and I you know I'm kind of glad that
somebody recommended this one because
this is local to our area unlike
everywhere that they're talking about
like I know where all that stuff is so I
mean I hate to say I'm sure that she's
not alive
but hopefully asically now they will at
least find her at some point and later
arrests and I mean hopefully like I said
they can get another search of that Lake
because it does kind of sound like that
that might be because I don't know weed
I don't know if you guys know but like
Orlando is like well Central Florida in
general it's just there's [ __ ] Lakes
everywhere I mean it's just like Lakes
why there's a town like not that far
from here called Land O'Lakes why would
they mix everywhere why would they
dredge it why didn't they send a diver I
don't know what they did it's like
because the last thing that I read about
it they basically just said the lake was
searched and they brought in cadaver
dogs and that the cadaver dogs seemed to
like you know seemed to like you know
okay indicate that there was something
of interest in there which doesn't
necessarily mean it's a body but it's
you know that's suggestive but as far as
I know they have not you know the
parents are trying to get another search
done maybe like a more stringent one
maybe they didn't maybe they didn't drag
it maybe they just brought the cadaver
dogs and you know maybe they did have a
diver but he didn't see anything I'm not
sure I mean that's a fairly big lake
it's not the biggest not like Lake Eola
or anything like that but um you know
which is downtown but you know it looked
like on Google Maps that looks like a
pretty big lake so I'm sure it's
possible that the body could be in there
I mean I'm sure like a lot of lakes in
Orlando have bodies in them that they
haven't found yet cuz that well yeah but
like I said there's [ __ ] lakes
everywhere yeah I mean if you're going
through Orlando like serial killers
probably don't [ __ ] bodies in there
all time alright so I got a couple more
cases that I want to talk about but says
we're probably about at the halfway
point yes we are a little bit past it
actually we're gonna take a break
refill drinks find the kitty do this
usual stuff so he's in the back
somewhere okay yeah well we have to go
find where she is like I said so what we
will be back in just a few minutes
oh my goodness oh my goodness
yeah that's your fun little Christmas
Bello Joey you're working the phones oh
boy yeah it's Christmas in March for a
baby cookie yes it is why are you eating
that don't eat that
what do you happy a little mint to lay
over there she was playing with that
earlier she likes to rub it on her face
Beijing likes to do that too I don't
know why
yeah
yeah
I'm so fluffy they're so fluffy
you're so weird pokey
why is it weird you just want to lick
all the fur it's like a little bunny
tail yeah yeah yeah
get warned help moving out from all the
playing can it jingles like we have I'm
not just gonna like her but okay honey's
and privacy you love true crime I love
true crime and I've spent the last three
years compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and vol 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the Caddy
murders the carry babies case the Frog
Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back for the second half
of our creepy disappearances yeah three
you walk in you all through the
apocalypse you're all alive as that
virus is out there totally it's gonna be
all right don't worry about it you're
getting like all you you were like
picking on me because I wasn't getting
all upset about it
we prepared I prepared I even got I even
got treatment who ever got treatment I
got defense I got everything I don't
usually get colds or flu you got this
[ __ ] I got this yeah yeah I got this
it's just another mission so the next
case we're gonna talk about this was
another one that was recommended to us
by a listener this is it the case of
ELISA
terney now this case even they've never
found this girl I have very very strong
suspicions as apparently many other
people do as well who is responsible for
this [ __ ] I'm gonna say allegedly
allegedly allegedly like there's no
proof but I do kind of feel like I think
I know what might have happened or I
think I know who might be responsible
for her disappearance maybe not but
we'll get into that now before we start
talking about the case I want to
recommend there's a woman that has a
true-crime Channel her name is Stephanie
Harlow and she actually did like a
two-part series on this case the Elissa
tourney case and she actually
interviewed Sarah attorney who is the
sister of the victim and who was you
know been um you know looking for her
sister all this time her sister
disappeared in 2001 and so that's like
really really good she had like a lot of
kind of inside information and it's
really long like it I think the first
part was like an hour and 10 minutes and
like second part was like an hour 15
minutes something like that so it's like
a really really long series that she
done so I recommend that as well if you
want like a more in
kind of like a look at it so this
happened in 2001 in Phoenix Arizona now
we got a 17 year old girl named Alice
attorney now she was a junior in high
school she was living with her sister
whose name was Sarah and they were
living with their stepdad whose name was
Mike now apparently their mom had
married Mike Turney
their stepdad when they were both fairly
young Mike had three sons of his own but
at this point in 2001 they were like
grown and they were like you know living
outside of the house or whatever now
before the now the mother passed away I
believe of cancer when ELISA was still
fairly young before that time apparently
it had been kind of like I kind of heard
their family like compared to like the
Brady Bunch like we'd we didn't say it's
like overstep brothers and sisters
everybody's just brothers and sisters
you know it was kind of one of those
things like you know with the classic
family kind of all like coming together
and we don't say stepsisters and all
that kind of stuff so but apparently
after the mom died I guess [ __ ] changed
a little bit now the interesting thing
was that so in this house there was the
stepdad and the two sisters now I
believe Sarah was a stepsister because I
think that Mike was her dad but she had
a different mom but she was around the
same age as Elissa either a year older a
year younger I can't remember but
interestingly after the mother died Mike
started treating the two sisters very
very differently like Sarah he would
kind of let her do pretty much whatever
she wanted she was like an older
teenagers like hey you want to go to a
party hey you want to do this then the
other thing you just you know do
whatever you want you you know he wasn't
real like strict or anything like that
however um with Elissa
he seemed like to go super overboard
with the [ __ ] now he justified it by
saying oh she's
like rebellious but she was a little bit
like she was kind of you know this was
2001 she was like super into Marilyn
Manson she was like you know smoking pot
and you whatever nothing super bad like
nothing that most people didn't do but
that's kind of how he was using it he
was very very strict on her and like
kept track of her and everything like
that
and that's how he would justify it to
Sarah and to Alyssa by saying oh well
you know you're kind of more of like a
bad kid or rebellious so I have to like
keep a closer eye on you and stuff like
that so so Hindman Alyssa didn't really
get along they were always kind of like
fighting and stuff so May 17th 2001 now
this was the last day of school before
that let out for the summer so it was
gonna be like an early release day I
think they were getting at it like 12:00
or 1:00 or something like that now Mike
the stepdad he was supposed to come to
the school um at whatever the early
release time was and pick up Sarah but
he didn't show up so she goes to like
her friend's house it to wait for him
now he doesn't show up until like 4:30
in the afternoon like at the friend's
house and he says um your sister Alyssa
is missing so he hands her the phone and
he's like you know you try I've tried to
call her and I can't get in touch with
her she's not at the house she's not
anywhere so the sister tries to call
Alyssa there's no answer now apparently
they go back to the house and they go in
Alyssa's bedroom and they find they
don't find her backpack but they find
all the stuff that was in her backpack
it's like scattered all over her bed she
has left her cellphone on her dresser
there is also a note next to the
cellphone the note reads dad and Sarah
when you dropped me off at school today
I decided I really am going to
California Sarah you said you really
wanted me gone now you have it dad I
took $300 from you that's why I saved my
in her handwriting it wasn't her
handwriting apparently because she had
like that kind of teenage like that big
loopy handwriting cuz you know how you
know I'm getting suspicious already well
yeah you'll be even more suspicious by
the time I finished I ran up this [ __ ]
so yes so now Sarah is on record as
saying she's like yeah she's like me and
ELISA
she's like you know yeah we fought like
siblings and everything like that but I
she's like I don't really like recall
ever telling her seriously like I want
you out of here so she's like we might
have said something like that but you
know they're teenagers and they're
sisters like siblings say [ __ ] like that
to each other all the time
now it should be noted that ELISA did
have an aunt that lived in California
and she had mentioned going to
California to live with his aunt because
she wasn't getting along with her
stepdad so this wasn't too crazy now
that same night that she disappeared uh
Mike Turney who apparently was an ex-cop
I don't he was an ex he was not a cop at
this point but I think he had been a cop
in the past he actually did call the
police and he reported that Elissa was a
runaway and he told them about the note
and everything like that so the cops
kind of like you know they they opened a
case but they didn't really do much
about it because you know yeah they well
they thought will run away it's like you
know yes she had talked about going to
live with an aunt in California oh well
that's where she went she was 17 years
old so they didn't like you know they
didn't like nor it very low priority
yeah but it was a low priority because
you know they thought well that's where
they typically come right that's true in
a 17 year old girls only most of the
time months away from being legally
[ __ ] yeah a big big enough and her
britches to do whatever the [ __ ] she
wants to do anyway yeah a lot of times
you know there's six months away from
emancipation yeah and then in certain
states I think the Mansa patient can
happen a lot earlier mm-hm and some
states if I think a 16 year old become
Ken
come apat emancipated yeah if they do
the right things to the for the court
yeah and if they can demonstrate the
right things yeah depends I think most
states have that yeah yeah but you do
like how to the court yeah you gotta go
to court I mean there are some 16
year-olds that can demonstrate my
parents are [ __ ] up yeah I want
nothing to do with that I can kind of
understand it some witch yeah if you
were 16 years old near parents were
[ __ ] and [ __ ] druggie yeah obviously
you would rather like go and live on
your if you could prove you could live
on your own I don't really have a
problem with that yeah I think a lot of
times its girls and that they could
prove that they have a boyfriend who's
stable yeah that's usually what happens
yeah it's like I have a place to stay
yeah we have money and stuff like that
which sounds weird that sounds weird to
a modern person you're talking about all
this me to [ __ ] and all this underage
stuff states the United States has a lot
of different states so I almost had the
age of consents that are like
Mississippi last I heard the age of
consent was 15 yeah you know I mean the
last time dependent we've talked about
this on the show before but it would
depend on how much older the boyfriend
were right it's like if you have like
some if she's 16 and some boyfriend's
like there's statutory stuff so but
here's another thing is is that that's
only in certain states
I don't think Mississippi Alabama or or
or Louisiana has statutory stuff I don't
know about that but I don't think stuff
to check as long as I think there's a
certain age of consent and then that's
it but it's it's it's [ __ ] that's kind
of reasonable 17 yes 17 usually like 16
17 they could do whatever the hell they
want to do but that but that isn't but
they can't like Inc they can't dance
nude or they can't engage in pornography
until they hit 18 right or remember or I
remember Louisiana because back when I
was in the Louisiana goth scene fish it
blew me away
but in Louisiana a girl could dance nude
at 17 yeah but she couldn't engage in
pornography right and I think when I was
up in Michigan Canada had strip clubs I
think where the girls could at least
back in the eighth
could dance nude at like 16 but it was
only topless yeah so that was old laws
though I don't know if they're still
standing yeah I mean that was yeah it's
a long time ago now when you look back
on it I mean [ __ ] well [ __ ] 50 now
yeah but that was only like 25 30 years
ago yeah but I get I guarantee you go
back and go look at Mississippi's laws
they haven't changed they probably they
haven't changed in Mississippi too
because they still have [ __ ] dry
counties we have that hairtail yeah
where there's counties that if you guys
don't know I know we have foreigners
here there were certain counties in
Mississippi where you could not see
alcohol
distilled alcohol yeah you could sell if
you are up to the next county to get
them yeah you could and then in those
same ones you couldn't sell pornography
so there were no magazines or in like
that
which was kind of weird gray area
because they had pornographic channels
on your damn cable and you're in that
County I don't you know I mean it didn't
make sense even back then I think it I'm
not sure if this is the same way but I
remember several years ago I know there
were certain either counties in Alabama
or the entire state of Alabama where you
weren't allowed to sell like sex toys
yeah it's almost all the Mississippi was
like yeah and see that's the thing that
like a lot of people might be [ __ ]
wigged out me spending so much time in
Mississippi having roots in Mississippi
it's a weird weirdest [ __ ] thing
states that have all this
anti-pornography anti [ __ ] sex toys
anti it [ __ ] alcohol had the lowest
age of consents and the [ __ ] you could
marry a girl at like 40 yeah it's
totally about it
well it's not backwards from the point
of view of who's right in these laws
you're talking about Sharia law it's
like Islam yeah it's encouraging you to
get married as and to have kids as young
as I am to that 12 year old yeah it is
this is well if you can bang her if you
marry her there it was it was weird
[ __ ] up it was weird
Christian yeah I know denominations the
you can only kind of call cults yeah
between Southern Baptists and
Presbyterians and [ __ ] all kinds of
weird you know I'm going off-track yeah
sometimes some people might be might
think that that shit's [ __ ] hilarious
though it's just the more country you
get it is kind of weird because their
interpretation of morality is very
different it is yeah yeah so yeah so the
cops like I said they did like start a
file but because the dad said oh she had
talked about running away and they knew
that she had family in California that
she left this note that was apparently
in her handwriting that that's where she
had gone they didn't like put it on the
front burner or anything like that
now a week after she left Mike told the
police that he had received a phone call
from ELISA and that she had said that he
was the reason that she had left cuz
they weren't getting along and she said
yes I'm in California and I'm never
coming back now the contents of this
phone call are only from Mike tourneys
say so he did provide the police with
phone records showing that there was an
incoming call from California at the
time that he said that it happened but I
don't think they know like who the call
came from or they don't know the
contents of that phone call so what was
said on the phone and who it was from is
kind of only from his point of view so a
few years go by um Mike is like starting
to tell everybody in the family he's
like look I I don't think she's in
California anymore now I think like
something really bad happened to her um
you know the cops aren't doing anything
I think maybe she got murdered he
started like going out to California and
like putting around flyers and stuff
like that like looking at it and looking
for like she was a missing person or
saying he was looking for anyway so five
years go by in 2006 and this is a you
know five years after she has
disappeared
there's this guy called Thomas heimer
now he was in prison in Florida and he
was serving time for another murder now
he had sent police a letter in which he
confessed to killing ELISA ELISA
attorney hmm now the cops pretty much
when they started questioning him they
knew that he was just making it up they
like a lot of the details and stuff like
that however because they open were they
reopened the investigation into her
disappearance they started noticing some
interesting things about Alyssa's family
life they noticed that even though
supposedly she had run off to California
to stay with an aunt that aunt had no
idea where she was no other person in
the family or no other friends of hers
had heard from her since um she had 18
hundred dollars in a bank account that
was not touched her Social Security card
had not been used which means that she
had not registered for any classes she
had not gotten a job or anything like
that she died
yeah so nobody knew where she was right
even the aunt that she was supposed to
go live with it's just like yeah she
never came here she never I never heard
from her friends ever heard from she
must have run away and somebody nabbed
her I don't think that's what happens
now okay
now when they started looking further
into the case they realized that what it
ended up happening like I said on the
day that she disappeared it was the last
day of school before summer break she
was a junior so it was only half day
they were getting out beforehand however
the police discovered that Mike her
stepdad had picked her up even earlier
than that like at 10:30 in the morning
or something like that or either that or
she hadn't even gone to school that day
one of those two things now apparently
he had picked her up before lunch and he
said oh I was gonna take her to lunch
why he would pick her up that early when
it was already an
early release day they're not really
sure and he was supposed to pick up Sara
later on that day but he didn't pick her
up like I said so that seemed a little
weird too now Alissa had a boyfriend
named John now the day that she
disappeared she had told him cuz it was
like an end of year party going on later
that night and she had told John yeah
I'm gonna be at the party later on I'll
see you later and all of her other
friends said that she had told them that
she would be at the party and that she
would see them now Mike said that he had
picked her up early that day like
earlier than the already early release
time that they had gone to get lunch and
that then they had gone back to the
house and they had gotten into an
argument and she had taken off that's
that was his story now when they started
looking into Mike's background they
found some very interesting things one
thing that they discovered was that he
was super paranoid his entire house was
covered with cameras inside and outside
some of them were hidden he basically he
recorded every single phone call going
into and coming out of the house and had
done for many many years there was there
was a hidden camera in like a vent in
the living room and apparently he had
one time like recorded ELISA had been
like in the living room like making out
with a boy or something like from her
school and he had recorded that like she
didn't know and I guess he still had it
like he had like all these videotapes
and stuff yeah how explicit did he get
well they were just making out okay you
know I mean it wasn't like sex or
anything so but they were just making I
couldn't get him on that right so they
asked so since the whole [ __ ] house
was apparently under surveillance
both the phones and the cameras and
everything like that I read at all times
there's a red flag
big time big time so the cops were like
oh well then you must have videotape of
the day that ELISA disappeared
yeah no video team Mike says to them Oh
well I've already watched those tapes
and there's nothing on there that you
guys would need to see they're like
where is it he goes like I don't have it
how much you want to bet yeah that's
pretty much exactly what happened and
the cops also said oh well you record
all the phone calls right like going in
and out he's like yeah generally it was
automatic and this and the sister said
this like in an interview that I was
watching he sounds voyeuristic to me
already yeah like like I said all yes
allegedly allegedly allegedly like don't
you know don't sue me just sounds yeah
I'm just saying but so they asked him
today said so you record all the phone
calls and stuff and it was automatic
like issue Sara attorney the sister she
actually said for as long as she could
remember it's like as soon as the phone
picked up it started recording you know
it was like an automatic everybody knew
and so yeah so they all knew that and
like everything tolerate this so no me
either who do that I mean they were
still kids yeah that was from some crazy
[ __ ] yes man so so the cops were like oh
well okay since she recorded the phone
calls
give us the tapes from that day you know
and maybe we'll get some insight into
where your daughter went and he's like
oh well it was turned off that day this
[ __ ] sister sister says like I
said she's like you didn't turn it off
it was automatic it's like any time you
picked up the phone it would
automatically start recording I wonder
how much he spent on this technology so
at this point because there was some
suspicious very sketchy [ __ ] going on
obviously so the police had probable
cause so they wouldn't search the house
and listen to this [ __ ] so they searched
the house and they find 26 homemade pipe
bombs and a whole bunch of guns like a
whole arsenal of guns and a 90 page
manifesto that this guy has written
apparently this guy had been like in
some kind of like he was an electrician
and I guess he'd been in a union and he
somehow got this weird idea that he was
a whistleblower and that people in the
Union were trying to kill him
he's [ __ ] car
yeah paranoid schizophrenia is the words
are the words that come to mind yeah so
for many years and like the sister said
the sushis like for many years it's like
he wouldn't even go to the [ __ ]
mailbox on the driveway without a
[ __ ] without being armed
they're like so he thought that people
from this Union route to kill him and
they interviewed like people who's you
know like yeah he just thought he was a
crazy [ __ ] you know what I mean
it's like we didn't know he's like he
was like there's nothing to it and right
he had drawn up a whole entire plan he
had all these bombs he was going to
drive this van he had it all like
sketched out and written out everything
he was gonna go to this place like where
the Union met and everything like that
and he was gonna blow it up is what he
was gonna do that was like the plan so
he so his story was that because he was
um you know he had whistle blown on
these people in this union or whatever
that they had taken ELISA and killed her
as revenge that was his story he's
[ __ ] crazy yeah clearly but like I
said you mean allegedly because he's out
now he's out now sue me if you want
Thomas a dick yes so they when they went
through his house to like other than
finding all these pipe bombs and like
[ __ ] like that
they found all the videotapes they found
the videotapes of like Elissa making out
with a boy on the couch they found what
appeared to be a snuff film like of a
woman getting tortured and murdered like
an unidentified murder it appeared to be
a snuff film I'm not entirely sure if it
actually was um but yeah so but they
didn't find anything from the day that
Alyssa went missing now the more that
the police investigated they also
discovered that Elissa had not only told
a bunch of her friends as well as like a
either a teacher or a counselor at
school and they found several letters
that were written by her in which she
alleged that Mike had been molesting her
yeah since she was a kid now they're all
started the crazy thing about this is
that apparently
she was younger Mike had made her sign
contracts that and they're like summon
it was like normal [ __ ] like um like
it's not normal to make your kids sign a
contract but at least normal it's like
you know just to behave be home by this
certain time or whatever but there was
one stipulation in there that kind of
like raised everyone's eyebrows was that
you know she had to sign this thing that
said Mike you know my stepdad is never
molested me or anything like that
Child Protective Services also
apparently had a record of him calling
CPS and saying if my daughter Alisa
calls and says that I molested her she's
lying don't believe her because we just
had a big fight and she wants to do
something like to get me in trouble
so they apparently had that on file as
well so I kind of feel like so because
of all the [ __ ] that they found like all
the bombs and all the [ __ ] that they
found in his house this is not credible
he ended up spending 10 years in prison
they put him in prison for 10 years
that's a long time he's out now like he
just recently got out but um it's weird
because so I was listening to this
interview with Sarah the sister and she
said you know this you know I grew up
with him he's my dad and stuff like that
she's like at first I was trying to like
deny but she's like now she really
thinks that the dad killed her sister
yeah but she's like this is this whole
like thing now because he has three
other sons that were grown at the time
that Alissa disappeared and they do not
believe that he did anything so that's
like this big like family rift it's like
this really messed up and there's even
if you if you go and watch that video
that I talked about earlier like this
two-part thing she had like um the
sister went to meet with the dad after
he got out of prison and she like
recorded the conversation and it's super
super awkward because the dad knows that
she thinks that he did something to
Alyssa so let's straighten this out the
stepkids
think that he did it but the blood kids
think that he didn't yeah no no I think
Sarah is actually his daughter it's
actually a blood relative I think if if
I'm sick but yeah the sons the older
sons they don't think he did anything
but this [ __ ] ain't jiving to me I mean
that's what I mean it just seems really
alarming one that he was apparently
planning essentially a terrorist attack
I mean he had it all written down he had
the bombs made they found the bombs in
his house yeah he had a whole arsenal he
had like the whole plans laid out like
the van he was gonna rent he had like
where he was gonna Park it he had like
all this [ __ ] right now was 90 pages he
had it all figured out and the fact that
that he had planned that and and the
fact that even going back when police
investigated they found out that the
Elissa had been trying to tell people
that he was molesting her for years and
no one had really done anything about it
I kind of feel like I don't know if he
actually had like I said allegedly I
don't know if he was like planning to
kill her that day or if it just kind of
happened oh maybe she said she was not
ready mouth that's kind of why I'm
suspecting it's like I'm not really you
know obviously I'm not there it's like
yes it could happen that she ran away
and got like I'll by somebody else but
and ratting somebody out isn't really
kind of like the proper way to
characterize that it's just telling the
truth maybe she's gonna tell the truth
yeah riding somebody out indeed yeah
yeah that's very different but maybe she
was she was gonna go to the authorities
yeah that's what was gonna have well
that might have been what happened maybe
they didn't have a fight and she said
hey I'm gonna go tell the cops like what
you've been doing right and so he just
decided to take care of the problem so
now it should be noted that a ser
attorney the sister she she has a
full-time job but she also you know all
of the rest of her free time she spends
it she has a whole podcast about it she
produces a podcast about the show about
the case she has like a Facebook group
she has like all that kind of stuff
because she is like determined because
she had to come around to the fact that
dad might have done something to her
sister yeah
um because she said she didn't believe
it at first but now she does and so she
is just like tirelessly working to you
know get down to find her and like
figure out so like I said never found
the body
no they have not found the body um and
he will not like say anything he just
says oh well he says that two guys from
the Union kidnapped her and killed her
and he says that he killed them but they
both of them are dead but they both died
of natural causes like at totally
different times yeah so he's [ __ ]
yeah so I think that dude has like some
paranoid schizophrenia issues clearly
because he's like inventing all these
conspiracies about himself well that
kind of covers his tracks though yeah so
I definitely feel a toasted to homicide
in this case that there is probably
enough reason to pry I will just
magically believe I'm not really sure
he's like he's older he's like pretty
grizzled looking but yeah he's 67 he
looked like he was in his sixties yeah
like I said he was in prison for ten
years for that for that [ __ ] that they
found in his house yeah because he was
yeah because he was clearly planning it
like a terrorist attack he had it all
figured out but that it's pretty scary
that he's like running around loose now
so I think that's kind of why Sarah is
like pushing so hard like to get the
investigation nope I'm going get the
investigation reopened because get the
body found or something because that's
this dude seems kind of dangerous I
don't know I was gonna say that they'll
probably figure it out but then what I
think about it now they probably
wouldn't because he's hidden the body
pretty well he's covered his own tracks
they'd have got him already
he'll die he'll probably go to the grave
with the secret that's really that's a
bummer yeah probably that I haven't
because I'm sure like everybody would
like to know like what happened to her
where did she go it's like what killed
her birds or somewhere yeah obviously
yeah I mean and this is Arizona so he
could have like to get her out to the
desert someplace because she did say
like she told like friends and I think
she told her boyfriend too that the
first time that he tried to molest her
you'd like drove her out into the desert
and that was like trying to like [ __ ]
rape her in the car and stuff so she's a
blood relative allegedly damn um yeah so
no that's her stepdad her mom died okay
now her mom died when she was young so
she'd been living with this guy for like
a long time right you know what I mean
so how old are we talking about 13 what
do when this happened leave his master
well she was 17 when she disappeared but
I believe the molestation allegedly had
been going on for several years at least
like since the mom died all right so
yeah that's it covered in tracks yeah no
talking special case he won't tell no
and and from his tone of voice like in
the recording like I said because I
listened to the conversation that Sarah
had had with him after he got out of
prison and it really does seem like it
might be a case where he's so mentally
ill that he's kind of like justified it
to himself in his mind or convinced
himself that he didn't really do
anything wrong because it does kind of
sound like you know what I mean because
sometimes if you're crazy enough you can
do that it's all right there if you ask
me I mean if Vicki told me this case I
say well that's the death the main
suspect and you know I'm just gonna say
and do probably did that I think and if
he did then that means he's not gonna
say anything and I mean what they
haven't arrested him yet then that means
they'll they don't have the evidence
they need for the conviction yeah which
tells me that he probably got away with
it
I mean seriously like the first comment
like that you know he doesn't have to
worry about us he's got to worry about
his daughter cuz his daughter [ __ ]
misses it is she yes she her she is like
tirelessly like I said she's got a
full-time job but her she has like a
second full-time job in all she is all
she does is like run a Facebook group
she runs a podcast she just like tries
to like she's like she calls
investigators every day it'll like ask
him like what's going on and stuff and
it just seems like but yeah like the
first but I watched like the Stephanie
Harlow like the two-part series that she
did about it where she interviewed Sarah
and I think the first comment like it
for that YouTube videos like I'm not
saying the stepdad did it but the
stepdad did and I'm like yeah allegedly
there's never been happy on that because
he seems like a crazy person I don't
think they're a bit they'll never be
able to prove it I don't know it's like
I don't know I'm just kind of hoping
they don't have to have to had confessed
to it or to do something to [ __ ]
uncover it right now speaking of
fucked-up families here is yet another
case that was recommended to us by a
listener now this is very very recent I
mean this is still ongoing arrests have
been made like as recently as a few
weeks ago this is a [ __ ] crazy story
so forgive me if it's kind of cuz it's
kind of complicated like a lot of [ __ ]
that happened in this so basically it
all started with the disappearance of
two half-siblings this would be Joshua
JJ valo who was seven years old and his
half-sister Ty Lee Ryan who was 17
now they apparently vanished from a
place called Rexburg Idaho now they were
not reported missing significantly by
their parents but by extended relatives
they were reported missing in November
of 2019 so when these two kids were
reported missing and police started
looking into it all kind of crazy [ __ ]
about this family like started coming to
the fore so let's kind of go back in
time a little bit
ten months prior no wait hold on one
second what what state was this again
Idaho Idaho yeah this is okay so let's
go back ten months to when the mother of
Joshua Val oh she's actually okay she's
the stepmother to the younger boy JJ and
she's the biological mother of Ty Lee
Ryan so this is like a another extended
family thing where she was you know she
had an older daughter and then she
married somebody else that had a kid and
well
so she's like their stepmom so Laurie
valo is the mom's name she's 46 years
old now 10 months before the
disappearance of these two children her
husband at the time whose name was
Charles filed for a divorce now
apparently the records now this happened
in Arizona in the divorce proceedings he
said that he was afraid for his life
from her like he got like an order of
protection against her and everything
like that now he was very concerned that
Joshua who is his biological son who has
autism he was very concerned that the
mom was not going to take care of him
properly was not going to like do all
the things that needed to be done to
keep him like healthy and happy or
whatever um he was also very concerned
about timely but there wasn't much he
could do about that because that was not
his biological daughter it was only his
stepdaughter but there are things in the
in the divorce proceedings where he was
like trying to get them to look into the
case and everything like that and he
also said that he wanted essentially I
guess it was like order protection would
be kind of like a restraining order
yeah but imagine um against his ex-wife
because he thought that she was a danger
to him and probably also a danger to the
children so apparently one of the things
that he kind of brought into evidence in
these you know divorce filings was that
she um okay so she had met this guy
while these two were still married named
Chad de Belle and Chad de Belle who had
he had written like a bunch of what they
call religion themed fiction I guess
maybe it was like a left behind I kind
of feel like it's probably like a left
behind apocalyptic rapture type [ __ ]
because apparently she got sucked into
some weird apocalyptic Christian cults
um where she apparent
I claimed that she was quote a God
assigned to carry out the work of the
hundred and forty-four thousand which
like I said some rapture [ __ ] right yeah
oh no no languages Christ's Second
Coming which was supposed to if a white
everything go blurry it went blurry okay
so this Christ's Second Coming was
supposed is supposed to be July twenty
twenty
okay and so you know not far mark your
calendar everybody so she's like
supposed to be like all up in that yeah
um and she apparently told him Charles
her husband at the time who was
divorcing her at this point that well I
don't really care about the family
anymore because I have quote a more
important mission to carry out she had
to get ready for Christ's coming back in
July now was she associated with some
concert yeah but this is yeah this like
weird yes it's called some it's called
preparing a people okay yeah yeah it's
like it's getting ready yeah and like I
said I don't just friend like when he
married her I don't know if she was
involved in it then but after meeting
this guy Chad day bail yeah it was like
a writer and I guess she got into it
through him I'm that's what I'm that's
kind of what like what I'm getting from
like all the news reports so so yeah
there was that whole thing going on so
Charles was getting very concerned that
she was maybe like kind of losing her
mind and she had kind of got sucked into
this cult and she was like you know kind
of going off the deep end a little bit
now it should be noted that this
religious group has tried to distance
themselves from this whole case as they
would you know on their website they're
saying it's like yeah we don't know what
they believe but this we're just kind of
like backing away slowly well maybe from
that kind of she took matters into her
own maybe but I I don't know if it's
just kind of like PR cuz they don't want
to be associated with this woman because
she kind of get got into trouble like
very recently so um so that's kind of
thing but they do apparently believe
that Christ is second coming and they're
trying to get everybody ready for the
rapture and every year let me talk about
this for one second okay
in case you guys don't know my
background in I mean I came up in a in a
fairly religious family especially like
my grandparents not so much my parents
but my grandparents and then you know
Christian Military Academy
I like Christian I like Christianity I
never really took us seriously you know
I'm not not passed the age of 14 or 15
yeah um I always liked apocalyptic [ __ ]
and the stories in the tell you know I
mean [ __ ] the movies and stories
about it well it's very exciting I don't
think it's really gonna happen but yeah
alright exciting is good way you know
it's a it's a cool prophecy it kind of
you kind of see modern things and things
that are happening at any one time you
say what mass kind of like what like in
the Book of Revelations you know until I
started to study you know dr. Robert and
price we've had him on the show before
and heard his version of what epochal
what what the apocalypse is about there
was revelations that that particular
book of the Bible is very sketchy and
it's taken out of context a lot somebody
was on some shrooms on there right yeah
all right everything that you talked
about about the Beast rising up out of
the sea and the Antichrist and the big
thing and the big battle at Armageddon
that was something that what already has
happened or supposedly already happened
all right that's not something from our
future that was from the future yeah
going on at the time and they were just
writing about it right politically and I
just want to kind of like you know
encourage anyone who's into
apocalyptical literature go ahead and
consult the Bible geek dr. Robert M
price he's really cool and listen listen
to his readings of all this stuff and
it's it's on YouTube when you read it in
the original Roman actually I think the
state of [ __ ] was written in the
what they call the Roman Vulgate the
vulgar Roman what was it go yeah do you
member no I don't remember okay Nate was
called the Vulgate I think so it was
called the it makes a lot more sense in
the original language it's not talking
about our future it's talking about
somebody's future but we're you know I
mean from the point of view of like
[ __ ] 1580 and there's a lot of [ __ ]
it's very sketchy in there and it's just
just that's not gonna happen
yeah it's not gonna happen is is
somebody who appreciates Christianity if
you're you know if you're into that
you're slightly misguided well how many
times since Christianity took a foothold
thousand years ago second coming in
Christ how many predictions about that
have been made right hundreds at least
100 say it is literature that's all it
is it's a literature and and what if
that's how it should be approached there
I think run with it there's nothing
wrong with it it's just literature it's
just don't take it like it's true
because it's not it's just a story it's
it's a story a lot of colorful wordings
in it and there's a lot of stuff that
you can use and to use to appreciate
today like when you say that this is the
apocalypse you know exactly what we're
talking about yeah
even even in Islam it translates into
Islam because they have some of that too
well yeah similar it's an offshoot it's
an offshoot yeah I mean kind of like the
same same way with Islam is very kind of
a good analogy would be like the the
Mormons the Mormons in Islam is kind of
similar in a certain way this Christian
reboot yeah it's way too but it's a good
way to put it
don't take that [ __ ] too seriously but
do take it you know take it as a piece
of Western tradition and Christian
traditions you know I mean it's good
it's good literature it's storytelling
well like I said I've always been
interested in religion in the sense that
I'm
interested in what it says about the
people that wrote it and the people that
believed in it at the time that it was
written yeah and I find that very kind
of lamb opens the second Samuel and all
I can all the symbolism yeah yes that's
fascinating yeah yeah yeah I mean you
you can use that in your everyday life
to kind of help you kind of like put
imagery into things that's what it is
the same way you do you do that with
Shakespeare yeah you know well yeah
that's guy I kind of see it the same as
oh yeah it's like that
yeah it's Christian literature yeah and
just take it for that don't [ __ ] get
wrapped up in this the world is not
going to end in that way if it does you
can you can you can say you know it's
kind of like something out of dad with
the old desert but the Old Testament the
New Testament but revelations didn't
make that [ __ ] happen and you know who
am I to say what God does but I'm just
saying that it's not as portrayed in
Christian tradition but go ahead good so
this group like I said preparing a
people now Chad de Belle who had you was
apparently the one that got her into
this group um he had actually spoken at
some of their events like I said this
group is trying there's like hey we're
not a cult we're just like you don't
have to come here we're not like record
if I don't know if that's true or not
cuz Scientology says that too and they
are definitely a cult don't sue me but
you know just about any small religion
is a cult yeah and and the thing is it's
like you know we just have a website we
give like lectures you can come and
watch the [ __ ] or not
they they make no secret about the fact
that they are trying to prepare people
for the rapture and the second coming
and that's really their doing which is
so funny because that's the rapture is
not in Revelation it somebody's you're
reading that into there yes so but yeah
so that so they kind of got all into
that now so all this [ __ ] was going on
and like I said Charles had filed for
divorce from his wife Laurie and said
she was a danger and stuff like that
however interestingly in March of 2019
he suddenly dropped the divorce
proceedings
six months later he got murdered by
Guess Who Laurie's brother
Alex Cox shot and killed him now Alex
Cox did not get in trouble because
apparently it was self-defense
or so they said this is a [ __ ] up
family you guys just like I didn't even
get to the bottom of this yet so this
happened in July of 2019
this happened in Chandler Arizona
apparently Charles valo
has gone to his wife's house
this is or has got yet at about 8:30 in
the morning him and the brother Alex get
into an argument I'm not sure about what
um you know because at this point
Charles and Laurie had been separated so
they were not living in the same house
anymore so he goes to the wife's house
he gets into an argument with the
brother now Alex comes in or he gets in
her argument the wife and then the
brother comes in and the nice - all
start fighting and then they get in a
physical fight Charles apparently hit
Alex in the head with a baseball bat
and then Alex shot Charles twice in the
chest and killed him now they did not
file any charges against Lord Laurie's
brother Alex because like I said it was
self-defense because I guess he had been
hit in the head with a baseball bat so
he was just defending himself and
everything like that so they're keeping
I mean they're keeping the case open
because at this stage you know once the
children went missing later on this is
kind of like part of the whole like
investigation but at the time they just
thought oh well they got in a fight and
he hit him with a bat so he shot him you
know fair play I guess well that's so
now I want to kill you yeah that's what
I mean so they didn't think anything of
it at the time now listen to this [ __ ]
six months after that December 11th 2019
Alex Cox the brother was found
unresponsive in his house in Gilbert
Arizona and later pronounced dead hmm um
they are apparently going to an autopsy
or haven't done an autopsy they don't
know they said that his death is
suspicious but they're not sure how it
was engineered or they're not releasing
that to the public so what
they do suspect that it they said it's
too early to know if foul play is
involved but they are doing an autopsy
and they're keeping that possibility
open so they must be saying either
poisoning or some kind of drug overdose
yeah so I don't so as far as I know
because like I said I tried to get like
the most recent like updates on this and
as far as I know they're still like
either working on the autopsy or they
haven't finished it yet or whatever but
they are they are saying they're not
ruling out that his death might be a
homicide now
interestingly in between in those six
months between when Charles valo got
shot and when Alex Cox turned up dead in
his house of an undisclosed or
undetermined malady uh Chad de Bell who
was who was the guy that got Laurie valo
into the weird Christian cult or
whatever it was his wife died with from
what at the time they thought was
natural circumstances but now they're
not so sure
hmm this was her name was Tammy and she
died October 19th 2019 but because after
the kids went missing and after Laurie
valo I told you this was confusing ran
off with Chad de bell-like they ran off
together like to Hawaii or something
like that so they went and exhumed his
ex-wife's corpse because they suspect
now that her death wasn't natural that
maybe she was poisoned right so this is
three dead people right and two missing
children
so wild-ass in one [ __ ] family I told
you this is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and I
told me it's like confusing now they
later found out so like I said they've
exhumed it her body um I believe in
December but they haven't determined
like whether it was natural causes or
whether she was poisoned or whatever
they found out that chad de Bell had
collected more than $400,000 in life
insurance
after his wife Tami died
now interestingly about the same time
that Tammy turned up dead
Laurie valo the mom of the two of the
kids that went missing and Chad de Belle
the guy that had got her into the cult
they started saying that Laurie's
daughter I'm assuming this is ty Lee the
17 year old had died a year earlier
which was weird because people still
knew where she was at this point she
didn't go missing until like a month
later now November 2019 the extended
family of the valas started to become
suspicious because none of them had been
able to contact either Ty Lee who was 17
or Joshua or JJ who was 7 like some of
the other family members like grandma
and stuff like that had been like trying
to call him and couldn't get any bead on
like where he was or what was going on
with them um so they started to get
suspicious and they um some several of
them like asked for like a welfare check
because you know how you can like have
the cops like go check on somebody if
you think somebody's in danger so this
happened in a you know I believe in
September or November of 2019 so they
said hey can you go like check out this
house and Rexburg where Laurie had
supposedly been living with the children
and see if they're there because we
can't get in touch with either one of
them November 26th 2019 the cops go to
the Rexburg house now Laurie
valo is there and Chad de Belle is there
cuz they're apparently dating at this
point they both said now Ty Lee was not
there the 17 year old they said that JJ
was staying with a family friend in
Arizona however when the police followed
up on this the next day they found out
that Josh Moses was not with this family
friend in Arizona and that friend didn't
have any idea what the two of them were
talking about so the next day the cops
turn up at this house with search
warrants when they turn up at the house
they find that Laurie and Chad have both
[ __ ] off
the house is abandoned essentially like
all their [ __ ] is gone no and they were
coming they left so on December 20th
police released information to the
public saying that these children are
missing and they are believed in danger
and you know saying old stuff about the
parents and everything like that now the
mother Laurie has repeatedly refused to
help out in the investigation and says
that she does not know where they are or
either says that or says that they're
staying with friends or whatever now
they also found later on they found that
either Laurie or Chad had rented one of
those like storage unit things live you
know what I mean like which always
reminds me of Silence of the Lambs yeah
they didn't find any bodies and hair or
anything but when they opened it they
did find like a bunch of both kids stuff
like their bikes their scooters there
was like a bunch of pictures of them
there was like a bunch of their stuff
like some of their clothing and stuff
like that was in this story why do you
store kids stuff that's what I mean so
yeah gross we thought that was very
weird that like all of this stuff was in
there yeah like I said was no bodies or
anything like that but in a few years a
bunch of their stuff was in there so
they thought that was kind of strange in
a few short years they've outgrown all
that [ __ ] so why do you why do you store
it yeah
that's again that seems very strange
they also found out they've they
actually found Laurie and Chad they had
run off to Hawaii
they were both in Hawaii they said that
the kids they didn't know where they
were and they were with family friends
there is no evidence that the children
went with them to Hawaii however they
did find Ty Lee the 17 year old her cell
phone was in Laurie bellows possession
so she took the teenager's phone but the
kids were apparently not with them and
they're not cooperating as to like where
they are now how many missing kids in
total two two it's a 17 year old and a 7
year old you know and the daughter is
hers
right the Sun is her stepson right he's
seven years old okay his dad is dead her
brother killed his dad okay you said I'm
saying this is very complicated right um
but like I said this is a very very she
has been arrested as if I believe it was
February 20th um she was arrested just
because she was supposed to produce the
children because she was being very
cagey about like where they were and
everything so she was like okay well you
need to produce the children by like a
certain deadline it was like January
23rd or something like that
and she didn't do that so they arrested
her and brought her back to Idaho now
this was only like a week or two ago
this was like the end of February end of
February and they brought her back and
she is still not cooperating as to where
these children are so all they're
charging her with at the moment like now
that she's arrested is like felony
counts of desertion and non-support of
dependent children right because that's
kind of all they don't have any bodies
they don't have anything like that but
the fact that she just left them
somewhere apparently and what where is
she saying they are she's either well
like I said at first she said at least
the little kid was with a friend in
Arizona but when they went investigated
he wasn't there so she's just being very
like she's apparently not cooperating
with you but not a good liar at all she
could see the little kid is with the 17
year old and they ran away yeah sure
like why she's not saying that I don't
really know like what her problem is she
seems like maybe a crazy person well
last one
pride um yeah yeah so she is like facing
a whole bunch of charges at this point
no murder no nothing like that because
they don't know where the children are
at this point an intelligent criminal
would have said she took that baby and
ran I don't know where they went
yeah you know what I mean if it could
she probably just not talking right like
I guess they put her in jail in Hawaii
um she has
five million dollar bail right and
they're going to extradite her back to
Idaho where the children disappeared
from or where they were last seen yeah
the the creepy thing about it is that
they're not entirely sure when the
children were last seen because they
know it was sometime in November of 2019
now the the littler kid was seen like at
school and so he was like at a private
school or like a special school because
he had autism and stuff so he was like
unenrolled from school Ty Lee who was 17
she had been homeschooled so they didn't
really say the school system didn't have
any record of her yeah um
now when he was taken out of school the
excuse that the mom gave was it's like
oh well I got a job offer in another
state like after her husband had been
shot and killed right and it's like so
we're taking him out of school cuz we're
moving somewhere else or you know and
I'm gonna homeschool him from now on so
they didn't keep track of him anymore
because she like officially on it so
what's the theory what do they think
happened they are thinking I mean no one
knows exactly but the fact that she's in
this I know they're saying it's not a
cult but it kind of sounds a little bit
like a cult I don't know if it's a cult
or if she just like took it too far and
like she thinks they're like the [ __ ]
rapture is coming do they think she do
they think they killed these kids I
think that that's the overarching you
know this is all allegedly at this point
because they have no idea where these
children are there's no evidence that
they're dead but there's also no
evidence that they're alive they just
have no idea where they are what she
could have done with them it seems very
strange that she had like this self
storage unit that had all their stuff in
it maybe I doesn't know where they are I
don't know it's just it's so [ __ ]
weird and the fact that three of people
are dead her her ex-husband yeah uh Chad
Day Bell who's she's dating now his wife
who they thought died of natural causes
but now they're like doing an autopsy
because they think she might have been
poisoned and also her brother that
killed the husband
and he turned up dead too and they don't
really know how he died either and
they're doing an autopsy in that
situation so they have his body yeah
those three they know right those three
are dead they have their bodies the
adults the kids they have no idea where
they are that's some weird [ __ ] and no
one has seen them since November of 2019
like I said I believe the seven-year-old
um you know they they kind of know when
the last time he was cuz he had been in
school and stuff Ty Lee might have been
missing longer because she was
home-schooled
and I guess no one was like checking her
so she wasn't like turning up at school
everyday or anything like that where
anyone would notice that she was gone
you know just kind of look to me what's
that looks like a long series of what
you would call in the Islamic world
honor killings or maybe the mom yeah
believes that really believes that the
rapture is coming yeah
and decided she was gonna kill the kids
to get into heaven
first well well maybe she didn't give a
[ __ ] about what I'm saying honor
killings not you know in the Islamic
world some girl she turns out she's not
a virgin a killer could be that this
might be something where you have a
bunch of a couple of hardcore Christians
so that are involved in this weird cult
maybe some of it they've made up on
their own and they're like we have to
take this one out because they committed
adultery we'll take this one out because
this one's cursed you know I mean the
little kid because it's cursed with some
kind of weird autism you take this one
out because she's you know I mean yeah
so maybe they're killing family and
family members because they're
transgressing although I kind of feel
like if Chad day Bell's wife was
murdered I kind of feel like that
happened and also Lori's husband getting
killed I think that was because the two
of them wanted to get together and they
were just getting like some impediments
out of the way yeah allegedly
yeah but they but if if they killed that
woman they would have justified it
religiously yeah perhaps like this one
has transgressed on this and that so we
can get her out of the way and then we
can be together because we're holy it
does seem like we're believers here
like some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but you know
this is all this is all just we're just
yeah we don't know I don't I just know
and this is like I said this is a very
recent case she like Laurie was only
arrested like a couple of weeks ago in
Hawaii and she is awaiting extradition
to Idaho as far as I know at this point
pretty much the entire family as well as
Laurie's like older son whose name is
Colby um like that geez they all yeah
they all think that she if she didn't
kill them then she for sure knows what
happened to them or knows where they are
so they're all pretty much telling her
hey why don't you like him out and just
admit it but she as far as I know is not
talking so I don't know what's gonna
happen with this cuz like I said this is
still like some ongoing [ __ ] we're doing
just we didn't even mean I didn't even
mean to do like [ __ ] current events
on this shitty but it's like so cop this
was one bit like somebody requested just
like a couple weeks ago and then I
looked into it I'm like holy crap this
is like the craziest [ __ ] it's a good
one I can't come up with anything
because it's like all that and in the
fact that the two kids go missing and
then they find out that like there's
three people are dead yeah and one of
them was clearly a murder but was
probably self-defense and then the other
two were not considered murders at the
time but now they're kind of wondering
hey maybe this was murders yeah that's
weird this is some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
there's like some messed up [ __ ]
families out there holy crap my family
is like so normal in comparison as far
as I know nobody in my family ever
murdered anybody yeah there's not enough
information to know not that I know but
yeah I'm like I'm gonna have to like
follow up on this [ __ ] because so you
gotta keep an eye on I kind of feel like
allegedly well there has to be some
reason why Laurie the mom is not
cooperating she knows what happened I'm
not saying they're dead I will see well
they probably are I hate to say it but
there has to be some reason that she's
not cooperating with the investigation
there has to be some reason why she
wanted them out of the way or why like
why isn't she just telling them where
she had a deadline they said look we're
gonna put you in prison unless you're
gonna put you in jail unless you tell us
where the children are by X date and she
didn't she would not do that they're
dead I kind of feel like they probably
are
I can and I kind of feel like maybe they
did that [ __ ] allegedly or she gave him
away she doesn't know where they are and
she doesn't know where they are anymore
because she just like didn't what she
thought she was gonna get raptured and
she want to deal with it gave him to
some other religious people something
like that because that's kind of
happened with that one girl 17 she'd be
old enough smart enough supposedly to
get out of it to smack the [ __ ] out of
her mom which sounded like somebody
needed to holy crap
but yeah this is so this is a [ __ ] up
case and I'm gonna be like father I
couldn't believe the [ __ ] details of
this [ __ ] when I was like reading it
like so I can't remember like who
recommended this case it was like a few
weeks ago but it's like thank you yeah I
guess because that's like we'll keep our
eye on the messed-up [ __ ] I kind of
curious to see where this goes
alright so it's getting kind of late on
a Saturday night I'm very fine keys I'm
very tired because Pookie kept waking me
up in the middle of the night like she
does she jumps on my chest at for the
morn it's like hey you up yes she looks
right down at you she looks and you feel
like her big ol a beady eye is like
looking in your face like hey you awake
yeah well now I am cuz you just jumped
on my chest you yeah your little 12
pound self yeah every much she weighs
now at her probably I think she was nine
pounds last time we took her to the vet
she's pretty small but she's very like
ones across my chest she doesn't step on
my [ __ ] crotch anymore every foot
with his ah she did that on purpose
that was the funniest [ __ ] ever she did
she got a reaction yeah well she like
well what she does to me is she'll come
up like around she comes up like around
the side of me and then she'll she likes
to like need on my shoulder but she only
likes it if its skin cuz I started
sleeping with like blankets and stuff
like piled on there because otherwise
she'll clog me in the shoulder yeah and
it'll wake me up and it's like she
doesn't like that so sometimes she'll
come up there and then she'll like move
the blanket she's like no I want flesh
yeah like that which obviously wakes me
up but yeah she woke me up at like 4:00
in the morning she woke up at 6:00 in
the morning yeah she doesn't do it every
night but she does it enough that but
it's she's so cute you can't do anything
about it and if you guys like follow us
on Instagram I posted like the funniest
little picture of her where I got like a
perfect picture of her like laying on
her back big smile
was a big smile on her face and like her
one of her little pillow I bought her
like all these like little Christmas
toys and she has like this little it's
like a little pillow with like a little
jingle bell on it and it was just like
stuck on that everything and she was
like hurray like laying on her back and
it was so [ __ ] cute it's a hilarious
cat she is [ __ ] hilarious she makes
she cracks this up like every single day
alright so well that'll probably do it
for episode 187 about four
missing-persons cases that you guys have
recommended so hopefully you guys will
enjoy it look into the [ __ ] like I said
most of these are fairly recent so if it
should go without saying but if anybody
has any information about these please
look them up it's like every single one
has a phone number you call the FBI or
whatever you know to give any
information to find out what happened to
these people and that will do it for
episode 187 remember if you liked the
show please like share subscribe on all
your social media just share everywhere
it's like we need more subscribers we
need more patrons if you want to like
support the show financially would be
much appreciated good our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
13 o'clock podcast WordPress com and
there is a button in the sidebar that
goes to a PayPal account if you'd like
to give a one-time donation any little
bit is much appreciated also if you want
to send us movies or something like that
you can message me if you don't have our
street address I will send it to you if
you want to send us some stuff anything
you send us we love presents and money
[Laughter]
for this episode we will see you next
time bye
[Music]
you
[Music]